Bump,
bump,
bump.
Uh,
uh,
he's double shooting me.
That means we're alive with the Kido
kid.
Kido.
I've been for data.
That's your new nickname,
the Kiddo kid.
That's hilarious.
The kido kid.
I'm just happy you're doing it man.
You know,
before we get into the UFC stuff,
Brendan and I were talking before this
about,
uh,
he,
he started the no sugar diet.
He,
he went,
he went straight Kido,
which is crazy for me.
There's no way he's ever going to do
this.
You're so addicted to candy.
He's the straight candy man.
Like you and my car.
Everything.
Ari Shaffir is probably the worst I've
ever seen.
Really?
Yeah.
He'll take a day off candy and he'll
just eat like pasta and bread all day,
like Kit giving us body candy and some
other floor.
Damn.
For me,
I think it was just like,
I've tried all these diets and I've,
and I've never got the results I wanted
to and going,
as soon as I started doing this,
everyone's like,
be careful man.
The cravings were gonna have headaches.
I'm going to have shit.
Um,
matter of fact,
I worked out more.
Was it hard at all over the first couple
of days?
Oh that's interesting.
Not at all.
Well you know,
if you talked to that Mark Sisson Guy,
he would probably say that your body
just adapts really well to it.
That's what I would probably imagine.
But I think like two to be sure you're
even in a state of Ketosis,
you got to measure your blood but it's
going to be annoying for you.
Just like it was annoying from,
I kind of have to find out where's the
right place to stab yourself because of
the fingertips weren't working for me.
It's like those little little insulin
when you checking your blood sugar.
Yeah,
they weren't getting through my
fingertips.
I guess I'm thinking of his fingers like
gas.
I saw all those ketalysis this is all,
I've got some serious councils up in
here.
I hear Ya.
Over the last shoot,
I think most guys doing their pinky.
My Dad's diabetic,
so I see him doing the pink yellow time.
He some days a little banana thing.
Somebody sent me one though and they
said there's a legit one now for your
breath at the ones for the breath used
to suck,
but now they have one that's legit and
it shows what Ha,
what level of it shows Jenica ketosis.
Really.
I have to look into that.
I don't even remember who sends.
I don't give a fuck.
I just feel good.
Well,
you know what I'm saying?
I just feel good.
I'm just gonna keep doing it,
dude.
You,
you're going to feel this is the crazy
thing.
You're going to feel this way and this
is how you feel now.
Like you know this thing in the middle
of the day where you get tired,
that's going to go away and I got that
when I went to,
I went to Mexico when on vacation,
had a great,
great old time,
but I said,
fuck it man.
I'm in Mexico.
I'm on vacation.
I'm going to go off my diet.
I'm going to have some fucking
Burrito's.
You know,
tea is getting in there.
I had Tacos,
I had it and then I said,
fuck it.
While I'm doing that,
I might as well get dessert.
Dude.
I felt like diggity dog shit when you
haven't done that and to know then right
away crash.
Yeah,
right away I felt terrible after eating
the cake and then in the day,
I mean I was just,
I could barely stay conscious.
I can't,
you can't do that anymore.
Yeah.
I think my thing was is I've always
wanted to do it but I never really had a
like a strict reason to do it.
Like something that just put it,
put me over to finally make the decision
to do it and I was thinking about how
much you do because I have a lot of
stuff going on.
I'm like dude,
I'm getting tired man.
I'm not,
I'm not doing that well like I could be
doing better just mentally more clear
and I'm working out doing all this stuff
and you and I have been talking about
for a while and I was like,
fuck,
I might as well try it man.
Cause coffee really does nothing to me
anymore.
I could drink six gap.
Tina's before I go to bed and sleep just
fine,
just fine.
Probably just get into rem sleep at all.
So I'm like,
I gotta do something and do it.
It's been great.
Wow.
That's amazing.
Good for you.
When it gets these 12 step programs,
then it gets easy because after awhile
you just look at food is like,
oh,
well this is what I'm supposed to be
eating.
That other stuff isn't food.
You know,
like you don't look at a candy bar like,
oh,
that would be good right now.
That's what's crazy to me.
I'm not like,
like you were talking about how you have
those Keto genic like greasy pcs or
whatever.
I don't even want to try that bullshit.
I should give him a shout out.
Quest labs sent us a bunch of stuff when
they found out that we were,
uh,
in quest.
Quest are great.
I know those guys,
they're great,
but like even like sweets or something
that simulates sweets,
I don't want that.
It's,
that's,
this stuff's good.
Like they have crackers.
You can eat these crackers.
These are like Kido crackers.
They're saltings.
I fucking hate crackers.
No,
I'm against carves in any form.
Those aren't really carbs.
I know.
Fuck.
They are the way they look anymore,
Joe.
Yes.
Okay.
You,
you're a new man.
I know,
man.
I feel good pain a week later.
I'm just 300 pounds I've been taken to,
it's called a key genics and it's
exogenous ketones.
These are,
um,
I don't know if that guy,
dom d'agostino had something to do with
this.
So many told me I need to research it
further,
but these are exogenous ketones.
You take this and you mix that with
water and it puts you in a state of
ketosis really rapidly.
Like within an hour.
12 carbs though.
Yeah,
but it's okay for the whole day.
I mean,
how much can,
I don't need anything.
All,
I have some nuts in my car covered in
cinnamon.
I'll snack on those all day.
Be just fine.
Never hungry.
You're very dead.
It's something's going on.
And I got knocked to my colleagues.
I have nuts.
Like Macadamia Homans Ooh,
I'm going to family.
Just good cinnamon on top.
You know what I do?
I eat those pistachios that are already
shelled also.
You got crack the shell open?
No,
they're already shelled.
All you're saying they're not shell?
No,
the bull.
The shell shelled meaning the shells
removed.
Oh,
word.
Yeah.
That's not the correct term.
Shelled shell will shit wouldn't,
okay.
Yeah.
Like um,
I mean what would be,
it's not come on your show.
No,
I don't.
I don't believe so.
I think they say shelled,
meaning that they have been removed as
long goes,
hey,
you want some shell?
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe it isn't.
Some shelled nuts.
I'd say,
well,
is there any we can on Sheldon?
Where you saying makes total sense I
now,
well,
whatever it is,
I buy them in the bag with no shells.
Let me just put it that way.
I don't like that.
A big giant ass bag and I just put it
out.
Just force feed.
I like the work.
It's like,
it's like with sunflower seeds.
I don't like just regular sunflower
seeds.
I get to have the shell like the word.
A lot of people do that man.
Like if you just got a plate of crab
meat,
fuck that noise.
I want the legs a crack open.
I see that weird.
No,
no,
there's merit to that.
Yeah,
no,
I get it.
I had some regular pistachios the other
day and I had to work for them and the
morning and they were kind of like a
flavor fall on the outside.
I enjoyed it.
Yeah,
like sucking on the ship times.
I just like to pour a coffee cup full of
pistachios and just eat that shit while
I'll watch TV.
I'll do a mix.
A little macadamia nuts.
Cashews,
all on salted.
I hate salt.
You're so healthy now.
What's going on?
I don't know what the
new fucking cheetos.
It's weird man.
Like Keto kid.
That made me like,
are you getting a lot of uh,
vegetables into tons of veggies?
You know what my big thing is,
I probably,
I made it every night for dinner since
I've been on the diet is I do like a a
shredded lettuce cabbage mix that I
saute and I put buffalo meat in it and
then I'll put like hot sauce on top of
that every night.
I know.
I look forward to it too.
Wow.
It's so weird.
Yeah.
Weight is going to melt off your body to
the first,
the first few pounds that you lose.
Obviously I'm not a doctor or supposed
to be just your body adjusting to this
new lower inflammation diet.
You don't have as much inflammation as
much water storage and your body and
your,
you just get rid of some of that and
then your body as it starts burning off
fat.
One of the coolest things is you don't
get those crazy hunger cravings either.
It's a completely different kind of
hunger.
Well plus it last longer.
Right,
because you're,
you're eating these fats so you're not,
your body is not spiking insulin.
Right.
It's like more of a steady.
Exactly.
Yes.
And the spike in insulin is fucking real
man.
Because like I told you,
I cheated in Mexico and then I cheated
one other time.
I just said,
fuck it.
I want a cheese burger and a milkshake
from this like old time sewing Eric and
Oh,
oh,
I was so dead afterwards.
It was like somebody poisoned to me.
I mean,
it was really,
she's so dramatic,
man.
Naw,
bitch.
No.
I really feel like I was having the
hardest time getting up off the couch.
I was like,
God,
I can't.
I just couldn't breathe.
It was like my body had just shut down
to process that garbage little shit.
It's like,
what the fuck is this?
I think the,
the only thing that took me a while to
get used to it was so much mct oil.
Yeah.
You gotta be careful with that though.
I text you yesterday I was running,
I took this a bunch of snow,
mct oil.
I swear to God.
I was like,
it's Venice.
I might as well just shit my pants,
right?
Like no one's gonna give a fuck.
I will just shit everywhere.
Yeah.
There's a tipping point with mct oil
where it just opens a flow.
There's no
fucking,
there's no like there's no like third
gear first or fucking six game man.
Where is it?
Is it like two tablespoons,
three tablespoons?
You're gone.
That should is the perfect storm for
explosive diarrhea.
If you want it,
clean out the pipes,
you don't need a Kalanick but it's not
like,
God,
I gotta take a shit.
It's like it's coming.
You better fucking figure it out.
Squeezing your butt up and you're
tensing up your innards.
You're trying to like clamp it down.
I have to stop running.
I was like,
I better think I pick him up game plan
and my mouth started watering like,
oh shit.
There's that battle that you play.
It's very similar.
The battle when you're trying not to
come,
you know the battle when you try not to
come loose,
just squeezing it dickish pledge.
It is.
It's very similar to that.
I don't want to shit my pants.
Pow.
You have willpower cause there's some
weak people in the world that just shit
their pants more than they shut.
You can't be my friend if you have,
you just give up and shit your pants
blue spot
to keep my butt tight.
You just got no willpower,
man.
Yeah,
but then I've Shit my pants before too.
It's like,
here's the deal.
It's okay to tap out.
Just don't tap out like a bitch.
Not at least put up a fight.
If you're gonna lose the fight,
be actually in a position where you have
to tap.
You just tap cause you,
you're sweating and it's just,
you have no other options.
Yeah.
Hey Calvin lighty one time,
said he shit his pants and then showed
up with regular beds.
Well,
that's one I just can't do.
He said that he couldn't make it to the
show at the ice house.
I looked at the,
because he shit his pants and I said,
what are you talking about?
He goes,
I shit my pants.
I can't come.
I said,
Brian,
these people came to see you.
They're here to see you.
And he goes,
what should I do?
I go,
go to a fucking bathroom at a gas
station,
take your fucking pants off,
throw them in the sink,
cleaned the shit out of your pants,
wring them out.
And they get over here with wet pants on
and a story.
How old is he at this time?
Oh,
like a year ago.
This is the go.
What should I do?
You got to show up,
man.
You've got to show up.
Like people don't want to smell shit on
you.
So if you could just get to the bathroom
for five minutes,
you can fix all that.
It's going to take a little work and you
going to wear wet pants.
But that's what you have to do.
Beauty,
painful paid the there.
Brian Cowen fans will fuck you up dude.
Who hanging out your pants.
Tell some jokes.
So he shows up.
10 minutes later it's pants or dry.
And I go,
what happened?
And he said,
oh,
I had a pair of pants in my trunk.
The worst liar pair of pants or your
trunk.
I don't know what.
I didn't even want to ask what was
really going on?
Get into it.
You Shit your pants as a grown man.
I mean,
it ain't a simple procedure.
There's some steps you got to me.
That's the next next shirt is I had
another pair of pants.
These pants in the trunk.
Have you ever had a pair of pants in
your trunk and you didn't know about now
versus shit,
your pants and go?
What is the odds that the pants are my
trunk?
Never.
I guess when I'm older I might,
I might have a baseball hat and there
I can cover my balls.
I love that story.
Kind of all the lies.
Shitting your pants.
I don't know.
I'm going to need some shits though.
I'm gonna need to see some stuff.
I do not know if it was a lie,
but Goddamn,
he smelled so normal.
I mean,
I would have just only calendar.
It's the best is the only he could do
that.
Like you shit all over your pants and
just find your pants.
I mean,
I guess it was like your pants away.
If it was like a clean log though,
you could figure it out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
If you look co felted coming out,
you're like,
oh,
okay,
we see what we got.
This is a blockbuster.
This is a fucking Mumbo roll of
submarines.
I figured out this is one of them lumbar
roads.
They either of those trucks that go down
on
gigantic star log shit like,
oh boy.
But then there's ones you're like,
oh my God,
this is 100% diarrhea.
Oh that mct oil.
There's no,
there's no guessing.
That short is no spray.
Paint your pants.
Now there's a feeling,
it's like your butt has different levels
of sensitivity,
but knows when you're going to blow out
a hard,
like a beefy pot roasts shit.
You know one of them thick,
dried out shits that's very dense.
Your but knows if I,
it's like,
look,
we're eventually going to have to sit
down here and there's going to be a big
one.
So I want you to get a magazine,
get your mind right,
so make sure you're fucking,
I pose to her.
But then there's the fire drill.
So fucking fire too.
And that's what I had in Venice
yesterday.
And she know he,
before you see,
you don't even look,
you can't see your asshole.
Even if you had to,
unless you're an acrobat,
use no way to even see your ass hole
with a high mct oil.
There's like,
it's like a ten second warning rick.
Oh Shit.
I'm saying like there's a certain level
of sensitivity for sure.
If you had explained that,
if he had explained the feeling of,
what is it like when you have to take a
shit,
you'd be like,
well,
there's different kinds of feelings when
you have to take a shit.
There's like,
eventually I'm gonna have to take a
shit.
There's a,
Oh God,
oh boy,
it's going to be a whopper.
But,
but it's a shit.
And then there's,
ah,
that terrace level five shit.
Yeah.
I arenia feeling like it's their signals
in your body that we always think of.
We put him in like one classification,
but they're radically different.
It's complicated.
It's fucking,
it is.
We break it down.
It's complicated.
The diary of feeling is super
complicated.
It's like,
hello.
Oh,
how do I know?
How do I know that this is about to come
flying?
My body starts sweating to brace
yourself,
son.
We were about to get active in some
foods to some foods are just like
sometimes spicy food for whatever
reason,
just break stuff loose off the walls and
there's the gods at math,
the latch fucking much.
It's,
it's fucking broken.
Fire hydrant come out of your ass.
It's complicated.
We can do a podcast for three hours
straight and shit.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
It's,
it's very important.
It's very important.
So really it's so easy on the MCT oil
kids oral to our story.
Yeah.
You're supposed to have like at the
most,
a couple of tablespoons.
Yeah.
Don't squirt that shit drinking.
It's not going to kill you,
but you'll,
you know,
you will shit your pants.
Yeah.
You'll piss out of your ass
straight up.
The big combination if you really want
to clean the pipes is those hoke load
shakes,
Kale shakes that I make with mct oil in
it.
Preach.
Whoa.
I started out in coconut oil.
Coconut oil was nice,
like scoop it out.
A couple of 'em,
you know,
extra virgin or whatever the fuck it is.
Get a nice couple of tablespoons,
throw it in there.
But then I decided to go hard and go
down to the paint called mct oil and uh,
I forget the number that I use.
Four or five tablespoons if fucked up.
I use four or five tablespoons for one.
I'm one of those blenders
does bro.
How many,
what do you,
what did he say that is about 16 hour,
not 20 ounces maybe.
So five scoops of MCT oil?
Or were you thinking though?
I don't want to see what happens
usually.
Usually I'm always down for more means
better.
And I didn't know back then when I was,
when I first started shitting myself.
See,
I knew come closest shitting myself.
I knew I still fucking do it.
I didn't know mct oil that was doing it.
I thought it was the,
just the intense amount of fiber from
the handshakes or from the um,
uh,
yeah,
all the,
you know,
I mean there's cucumber in there and
carrots and there are a salary rather
and ginger and garlic and usually like a
piece of fruit,
like an app or something like that.
Like there's so much fiber.
I thought it was just blowing everything
out.
But there's a big difference between now
when I had the extra mct oil,
it's like it's,
it's like a turbo turbo engine.
Is it lubing the everything up.
Why is that?
Just gets in there and wreaks havoc.
It just gets in there and fucking why
does it make it all come out as liquid?
Like what is happening?
It's complicated.
So complicated.
How the fuck does that work?
But it seems like it would be a good
thing.
Like it would be uncomfortable but like
something like that would clean you out.
I think it's a good thing probably.
I feel like it.
I hope so.
Yeah.
I hope so too.
Anyway,
good source of healthy fats.
He just take it easy fucks.
Yeah.
He's the man.
More is not better.
Yeah.
So a big UFC this weekend.
That's one of the reasons why we've had
down here and just start talking about
shitting their pants and even 25
minutes,
man,
talking about whatever though.
No,
a big UFC
this weekend,
but I was talking to you through tax.
I feel like no one's really talking
about [inaudible] 97 because the connor
that straight up [inaudible],
that's all I referred them now,
the two best pound for pound fighters in
the world.
Universally heralded,
two best pound for pound Christ John
Jones and Demetrius mighty mouse Johnson
fighting on a car this weekend and no
one's talking about I ain't Anthony
Pettis is on that bitch versus Barboza.
Yeah,
but Jon Jones,
uh,
in my opinion he's number two.
Not that he's not that he's not awesome.
I just,
I just go off technique.
I think that Demetrius Johnson is on
another level.
I think he had my eye on another level
because it's so small.
But I think what Jon Jones does and his
risk of losing is so much higher than
mighty mouse is,
and he's destroying dudes.
Yup.
And not training and high as,
fuck,
you're,
let's toss that on top of it.
You got good points there,
but just because you didn't train,
it doesn't make your performances more
valid.
Like because you beat Daniel cormier and
you did coke three weeks before,
you still have the same fight with
Daniel cormier.
It just because you went five rounds
with Alexander Gustafson and struggled
because you didn't train,
you still struggled.
So although I agree that Jon Jones at
his best is the Motherfucker,
I mean Jon Jones at his best when he
choked out,
Leo Machida when he just dropped him and
walked away.
I don't think,
yeah,
I don't think get the contest because I
think John,
the way he's being guys,
he's facing tougher competition.
You could argue that and his level,
his level,
his margin of error is so much smaller.
Like let's say Dj has one off night and
someone lands,
lands a big like right hand on him,
he'll figure it out.
And that right hand is like Atlanta
again.
If Jon Jones has an off night,
again,
even Osp and Osp lands a huge left hook.
It's over.
So it's true.
You've very good points.
These are very good points.
And thinking about the legends,
he's beat mighty mouse,
mighty mouse.
Next fight.
If he gets passed,
so Hutto he's fighting a winner of the
ultimate fighter.
That's what the fuck we a result too.
There's just no one for him to fight.
Whitney five Benevidez no,
no.
His next fight.
They said if he wins this fight,
he's going to fight the winner of the
ultimate fighter.
That sounds crazy,
but that's,
that's where that's,
that's who says people,
tiny people.
People don't look at those little tiny
guys.
It sucks cause he's so talented.
He's so good.
I actually think it's better for the
sport.
I love Demetrius Johnson.
I love Dj.
I absolutely love him.
Think he's great.
I think it's better for the sport of
pseudo wins.
What?
Yeah.
Why do you say that?
Because of his,
his upbringing,
his background,
Olympic gold medalists didn't go to
college,
just pursued the Olympic straight out of
high school and one gold.
The youngest ever doing gold.
You know,
his Mexican roots.
I think UFC could use more of that.
Dj needs a nemesis.
He the old like although had mcgregor,
right?
All those never been bigger.
Now we're,
I think DJ needs a nemesis and if he
beats them,
we don't have one.
He fights the fucking ultimate fighter
winner.
It's true.
Or unless he beats him barely,
you know,
who knows.
But even then,
look,
so who knows not to joke.
The best wrestler in mma today,
I mean arguably that's competing in 125
pound division.
Who the F who's ever had more wrestling
accomplishments?
He's an Olympic gold medalist.
Malice mean that's the,
the beast of the beasts.
So you know,
he's a winner.
He's just a straight winner.
The real question is,
is that cut to one 25 too brutal cause
he's look good in his fights.
The scary thing to me though that he
looked better if he didn't cut.
I always think guys would,
I always think they would.
A guy like him,
I wonder,
I'm like a wonder if he's got that
restless mentality to always be the
biggest guy.
Look what he did.
Cutting that weight though.
Like he has it down to a science.
So usually wrestlers are a beast at it.
Like DC.
Amazing.
Pendo.
You're talking about guys who never
really missed,
wait,
why am I rumbled?
Back when he used to go down from like
200 plus,
it was just unhealthy.
One 70.
It wasn't saying that just unhealthy.
I can't believe no one was like,
God,
I feel like it's a bad idea.
You might die.
Um,
and then data was like,
Nah,
I got this dead.
Dot.
A.
That's,
I can't have that shit.
But they said dot.
Only had to lose three pounds a week of
the fight.
Still hold all.
I'll just say it.
You better know your weight cuts.
Yeah.
I think there was a lot of other issues
going on there.
Physically it was just wasn't prepared
for that.
But there's a big difference between him
and a guy.
Like just being silly.
I know.
So who does the fucking best in the
business?
He's a master at weight cutting.
You just look at his,
you know,
his wins all submission.
I mean,
all,
uh,
decisions.
His level of competition.
Dj,
I think he's number two,
pound for pound.
Best.
Good luck,
man.
Yeah,
is a motherfucker.
He's an artist,
man.
He's my favorite guy to watch because
you just don't get to hit him.
You don't get to.
So I,
it works well.
How it works is he's going to be moving.
You're going to be reacting,
you're gonna think he's gonna go left.
He's going to go right.
He's going to punch you in the face
while he's doing it.
He's going to circle out leg kick you on
the way out and then enter when you
think he's going to exit.
Go to the right when you think he's
going to go to the left and constantly
switch between takedowns and punches and
he gets you up against the cage and he
drops down for doubles and comes up with
an elbow and it's all creative.
This is all flowing together and there's
no one with better skills than him now,
but I don't think that makes him the
best fighter.
It's a good if that makes sense.
But some still think if I'm Dj,
I'm gonna sit there and God,
how,
how the fuck can I become a draw?
I'm tiny.
People don't give a fuck about tiny
people.
Let's see,
the one guy who's beat me,
dominick Cruz is a massive star.
I need to go up in weight and fight
Dominic Cruz.
That's the fight.
Well grab the mic after beat so Hutto
and go dominic,
you though.
You're the last guy to beat me.
Especially in the UFC.
Before that it was a homeboy,
the fricking Irish cat.
I forget his name.
Anyways,
he just needs to get on the Mike and go
yo the last guy to beat me.
Prick.
Picket.
Yeah,
exactly.
Pick it.
Beat him and decision English guy.
Yeah,
my bad.
My bad.
Loved that guy might happen.
But he just needs to get on the mic and
create some sort of hype like you're in
a pseudo thing till the common fan.
These are two tiny dudes.
It's hard,
but to stay at one 25 it ain't man.
You're not going to become mainstream.
Knocked can become,
you're not going to make a lot of money.
Mm.
Well I wonder though.
Well maybe you're right,
cause if so who don't beat him then
maybe don't.
We got a little bit of drama.
Yeah,
well we'll see.
Looks it's not outside the realm of
possibility.
So he knows this thing for him.
So hutto beats them and talk some shit.
It's kind of back and forth fight and
then they fight again.
We'll watch that three match or let's
say just destroy.
So Huda,
so Hutto don't wait for the ultimate
fighter winner.
We don't give a fuck about those small
getting loans with fighter.
Get on the mic.
Call out dominick Cruz on.
I'm wanting to see.
So who don't you versus someone like
Benevidez.
Me Too.
I wanted to see,
so who'd o versus like a real veteran,
but then if let's say fights Benevidez
in Brendan's visas beats him.
He went Benevidez mighty mouse to bet
three three.
You do?
I do.
Yeah.
Again,
I get it.
You do.
Everyone else does not.
And I Benevidez is,
I love that dude.
Well,
there's two ways of looking at it as
excitement junkie and as a fan of the
art form.
For me as a fan of the art form,
I want to see dj with as many different
tests as possible because I'm a big fan
of technique and movement and I think
he's the highest expression of technique
and movement today cause this is
combinations.
The way he went away,
he stifled Dodson.
You don't stifle Dodson.
Dotson's a hurricane.
You got cows flying around your yard.
You know the fucking satellite dish.
We'll take your head off as it comes off
the roof.
Yeah,
he's so fast.
How about with the bag of teen off?
When he fought off,
he out cardio at him.
He was on a pos on epo on the owl
carney,
five pounds and he out cardio to him.
What the fuck teen offs got that style.
That's that Russian style that sometimes
works,
but sometimes it doesn't fucking,
it's really those guys.
They can see the shots.
Tents,
every punches.
It works at heavier.
It works at heavier weight.
He buckets,
you know,
fucked a lot of people up.
[inaudible] five you got a mother
fucker.
But I just think,
like you said,
there's from a purist point it's like
yeah,
mighty mouse.
Keep doing your thing as a guy looking
at what's best for him cause he's gonna
fight right.
He's just keep fine.
How can we make the most money and get
you the most fame and the best
competition.
Dominick Cruz,
I agree with you.
It's the best,
best matchup in that they're virtually
identical sidewalk in size wise,
only 10 pounds off.
Yeah man.
And they're both talking about world
champions,
the highest level and what type of a
super fight.
We're not that far off 10 pounds at one
25 though it was actually quite a lot of
weight because it was a hundred pounds.
It'd be 10% there's a lot of weight,
but they could figure it out.
You know what I'm saying?
Like you could risk that for that big of
a payday.
Well or if Mickey Mouse has fought at
that weight before and if he just did
it,
if they gave him like six months,
you give them six months,
we can do some squats or dead lifts or
whatever.
And the issue,
the issue is,
is cruise,
right,
so it's cruise has uriah,
let's say he beats you or I,
if we go with the vegas odds he beat
Uriah but then he has tj.
Well I think is going to go with Dodson.
If I had a gas like what the big fight
is at one 35 rematching Tj and Dotson
cause that was the finals of the
ultimate fighter.
Hundred a percent and both guys are
light years past where they were them.
I would like to see how dots and deals
with the champion Tj because Tj lost a
razor close decision to dominic.
Right?
Agreed.
Very critical.
I actually had tj winning very fucking
close fight and you know dominick Cruz
is a master.
I mean he is just a mass straight master
watching him move and it's footwork
inside the octagon and the way he mixes
things up.
You're like this fucking kid has been
out essentially for four years except
for one fight nuts.
Crazy.
Not One fight was like a minute
something and just stuffed stormed
Mitsui Guy.
So you're watching this guy move around.
I mean this is a guy who hasn't
performed under the pressure of the
cameras for all this time.
He still puts on this mass to pull
performance,
the best brain in MMA that I've ever
been as a wizard as far as him talking.
But I think you so,
but you have to,
so you got to keep tj active yet keep
dominic af active but dodson and and Tj
is um,
months.
A motherfucker for sure.
Monster fight,
but for,
for the the guy who's going to be left
out and fighting a no name or ultimate
fighter winners.
Dj.
Yeah,
that's weird that we're definitely,
what's going to happen.
Almost positive.
We should,
we should,
we are arguing this fake point.
Let's find out if it mighty mouse
Johnson will one day fight the winner of
the ultra.
Maybe I'm just full of MCT oil.
I'm making shit up.
That'd be a weird thing to make up.
Usually I'm right on this stuff.
I feel like he does fight the next.
It was very challenging.
Vaguely familiar when you said it like a
vaguely,
it was like [inaudible].
Is that right?
I'm almost positive.
I believe you.
I believe you will find out.
Yeah,
you got it.
Is it Jim?
Demetrius Johnson isn't scared of tough
24 winters title shot.
I just don't care.
Wow.
So yeah.
So the winner gets that title shot.
Yeah,
that seems crazy.
Like I get it when you do that with
girls cause there's seven of them.
But with these guys,
is there any way we can help dj out
anymore?
You already fucked him on the xbox deal.
Is there any way we can do something
with them,
man?
Yeah.
Oh,
I think he's making money off of twitch.
Is he making money?
Does play video games on there?
Oh,
he's a legit Gamer.
He's addicted to gaming.
I just don't think it gets the credit he
deserves.
I tell every young fighter you want to,
you want to emulate someone.
Emulate this guy.
He's better be tiny though.
Yeah,
you gotta be tiny,
but you can emulate a version of it.
At one 70 you could emulate a version of
what he's doing at one spot.
If fricking the Kido kid here,
17 at six four,
210 pounds,
can't be like watch mighty mouse.
Like no fuck you can't.
But you can emulate a version of it.
Like Rico Verhoeven,
Rico Verhoeven is very technical,
has incredible cardio and he's a,
he's a fantastic kickboxer and he's a
big motherfucker,
right?
MMA now.
Yes,
he has.
Good luck.
Good luck finding him.
Jesus Christ.
And he's trained at Aka.
Oh fuck.
Who the fuck's to?
Well,
the only,
the only problem mobilizes in the
beginning of their career.
They're susceptible to punches during
like takedown exchanges.
Like remember when random and knocked
out cro cop.
Dude,
I ever,
Woo.
She's Cro.
Cop was looking for the shot,
true and random and came at him with a
punch and just leapt at it.
When they can't ground lease their hands
in.
The gloves are so small.
Like,
you know,
in kickbox he can get away with a little
more or even in glory,
whatever.
But like your boy Pat Schilling,
right?
Like he should be merck in some of these
dudes.
But Oh,
showing you jo Shawn.
Sorry.
Shy.
Yeah,
Palestinians.
I was like,
who's this pat fellow with Joe Shoen?
Like he his standup,
some of the best in the world.
Yeah,
you seem fight mma.
It's not this.
He can't fight the same.
He's worried about the takedown and so
he's opened a knockout.
So you'll see me get knocked out by a
guy.
We were like,
dude,
if there was no takedowns he would fuck
you up.
Yeah,
100% feel like yelling at another crowd.
Yeah.
Well he's only doing that now.
I think he's going straight kickboxing
now.
It's smart man.
Quit messing with M and ms in his
thirties to you in your thirties the
game and it's full of grapplers known
standing with your crazy.
Not only that,
you might find yourself across the cage
from some Ncaa Division One national
champion and you are not stopping the
down.
You're not only your time,
but he doesn't give a fuck about
exciting fights.
He will ride you for 15 minutes and
loved every minute of it and say,
don't care.
Face was elbows and the only problem to
be able to get up.
I agree.
It was a big difference.
She's standing up with someone or guys
are used to slipping and moving and
anticipating angles and someone
literally holding your fucking face down
and force feeding you elbows.
Head has nowhere to go.
But also with,
with uh,
Joe Schilling,
it's more of like,
I just don't see the payoff for it boss.
So there's not a lot of money in kickbox
and what he's doing.
I'm hoping Bela Tarr brings it up cause
they got Bella kickboxing now and a UFC
now has glory so that UFC has glide
paths,
right?
Yeah.
Fight Pass is they're carrying glory.
Espn is also carrying glory.
I saw that.
They're smart man.
It's all fucking awesome product.
It's just right now people don't know
about it.
You have to tell the guy's story.
That's the problem.
We need to be invested in these guys
that would fucking Joe Schilling
stories.
It's great man.
But we have to be invested in care about
the guy fighting.
Otherwise it's just two guys kickboxing.
I think if someone like Hbo got Ahold of
it,
if they did it the way they do hbo
boxing,
if they had like a Simon Marcus versus
Joe Schilling title fight like two guys
who have gone to war and have this crazy
history behind them where marcus stopped
him in one fine.
And then Joe Schilling Stop Marcus in
the fourth round of this insane fucking
war.
Did you,
were you there in La for that fight?
I watched it.
I was not there in person.
You I supposed to go with you actually
fucking Mooglie when he uncorked that
right hand and you see Simon Marcus go
out,
you're like holy shit.
And it was in the fourth round.
When there's that moment when these guys
have to fight three rounds and if the
fight is draw at the
end of the third round,
they go to a final final debt.
What do they call it?
What are they going nation don't call it
sudden death.
No,
he can't.
That's tough.
That's rough.
Especially with the current debt.
So they go to this one more round and
uh,
when the one more round he'd see polls.
Guys are exhausted,
tired and sign and Marcus had spit his
mouthpiece out a couple times.
He got a point taken away from him for
it and uh,
it was looking like Joe Schilling was
going to probably win.
So Simon Marcus is going after him and
Joe Shelley just uncorked beautiful
right hook that just completely shuts
the light out on shot outside.
I think if Hbo got Ahold of that and did
a 24,
seven day honey Dick,
me more than amy,
I will.
If they do,
if they do a 24,
seven,
I will buy anything.
I don't even know the two Mexican boxers
and I'm so invested.
I'm like,
I can't wait.
I cannot wait.
They,
they do a better job than anyone.
You could smell the tacos and hear the
music and you feel whole family.
I know he going to warm to when they get
good,
but those things,
they do it the best.
No one does it better than him.
You know what else they do?
That's good.
That I like when they do that thing
where,
um,
the face offs with less Kellerman yeah.
With Max will they sit across the table
and they both talk about like,
it's tough if they don't speak English
though cause a delay.
There's a little bit like with Canelo
with Canelo and Amir Khan.
I was watching like,
well,
okay.
You can see his air piece.
It's a little tough.
How much English is can no,
no,
he doesn't know.
I'm very good.
Yeah.
Very good.
The money's over here,
right?
They all want to come over here for the
money.
I would think you would just learn a
little bit of English.
Nothing makes sense.
Especially if you want,
you know,
if you want to get big brands over here.
Those shows though,
like a showtime has those ones they did
for mayweather's fights.
What do they call them?
All access.
Yeah.
Those,
those are big men.
They're good,
but they're just not the same as it as
as the original 24 sevens.
Nothing can fuck with a 20 verse seven
Ufc has done some pretty God damn good
ones embedded.
They're good.
The one on when cowboy fought,
I'm Rafael dos Anjos.
Yeah,
they're great.
Or like,
yeah,
the run went there.
Good.
I'm with you man.
You're bat shit crazy.
He's been an entry on 20.7 what do you
think they got the idea and that guy's
voice and leaf is elite.
Shriver's
let's steal that guy and bring him the
UFC.
Yeah.
Who Do they use for the EOC voice?
I don't know.
Yeah,
that Liev Schreiber guys.
Weird because you don't recognize that
it's his voice because his voice is
somewhat in distinctive in some weird
way.
You know?
Like just like Liam Neeson.
If Liam Neeson was doing a voiceover for
something,
you would know it's Liam Neeson and that
would kind of be distracting.
I agree.
But with Liev Schreiber,
he's like,
Oh,
this guy is smooth.
It's fuck like God damn it's it.
It's how you get out of it.
For that guy,
I would literally,
I don't even know him.
I do anything for him.
Yeah.
That's all he'd get out of it.
He smooth.
Yeah.
I mean UFC could get someone else.
Well if you like a Morgan Freeman would
be,
well,
that brings up the thing that's going on
this week with Mcgregor.
Um,
we got caught off guard last episode.
Jamie and I were talking and just out of
nowhere,
it's just breaking news.
And Jamie brought it up to conor,
announced his retirement and I said,
I thought it was trawling and I had the
exact same reaction.
I was like,
he's trolling,
he's fucking around.
It's all weird.
He wouldn't,
he'd be more eloquent than that.
He'd be,
he,
he blew it up,
put it out better than that.
But yeah.
And then the news started coming out and
I also started thinking,
well,
maybe,
maybe something happened in training or
maybe it was because of that guy that
died recently and people were saying,
you know,
they were shocked that I didn't know the
full details and the guy's dad,
honestly,
with things like this,
like,
you know,
it's going to happen and um,
it's unavoidable.
It's,
there's a certain amount of risk
involved in any extreme sport.
Plus that's the exception.
Yeah.
It's going to happen.
That's the exception.
It is like seeing mad at peanut butter
when someone dies.
It's like,
I'm still gonna need peanut,
you know,
it is exception,
but I was waiting for all the details
come out.
I don't think they've done an autopsy
yet.
They don't think they know.
I don't either.
I and I,
I didn't think that with connor,
and I don't know if this is,
I don't think it's sharing too much
information.
When Khan and I had lunch together,
I just talked to and he kept bringing up
as a reoccurring theme when we were
talking.
He goes,
the media man,
like for this,
it's such a beast.
He's like,
like I've done interviews before,
but you know,
it's different.
Like he's not a guy where when any other
fighters sit down and do an interview,
they're really not selling the fight.
They're talking about th their camp and
they're doing the same thing over and
over.
Connor's up fucking master that we've
never seen do it before.
So he's coming up with original content
nonstop.
He's on,
you know,
like when,
when he came on our podcasts,
he,
you could,
he was done.
He did the whole car wash.
He was exhausted and we came down.
You could tell him he was thinking and
just start spitting out gold.
He's just a beast,
man.
So to have that guy fly around the world
and do all this shit,
I mean,
at the end of the day,
we got to remember this is a sport.
This is not the wwe.
So to keep putting on the spectacle,
like it's similar to wwe at some point
yesterday,
man,
what these guys do is it's a real,
real,
we're in the HERP business.
He has to focus man.
And I just feel like,
I think connor's to blame too,
Dana,
is to blame.
I think both of them just need to talk
because if connor before it's bad
planning on him,
bad planning on Dana,
if he just went to listen,
I've sold this flight more than anyone.
Man,
this is nuts.
I have to,
if I lose this next fight,
I'm screwed though.
A problem is it sets a precedent.
Now,
if I'm looking at it from a,
as a businessman,
if I was,
if I was a businessman,
let's pretend,
okay.
Uh,
I would say this sets a precedent.
You can't let someone decide what press
they do and press.
They don't do like you have an
obligation to fulfill certain
responsibilities like with the media for
sure.
Like,
like create hype.
But the question is,
but the question is like when do those
responsibilities move into like a purely
digital realm and when do those
responsibilities only in showing up
places,
physically old school going places.
Because like there's nothing wrong with
the occasional press conference,
right?
No,
but,
but also you can accomplish way more
with a few fucking viral videos than you
ever could.
Going to some weird interview with two
people that aren't mma fans.
And I think he made a really good point
about that doing this fucking these
morning shows,
they make them go do where you know,
nobody knows who the guy is or the girl,
they don't give a shit about MNA.
Yeah,
they don't,
they don't want to talk to them the way
you want to talk to him or I want to
talk to him.
You know when I'm talking to connor like
before a fight,
I'm trying to find out what's going on
in the head of a guy who's going to
engage.
One of the most exciting things that I'm
going to see all year.
No,
you're not going on a morning show
going.
How about that cauliflower?
Huh?
How'd you get that?
Shut the fuck up.
But also I know,
but congress is a guy where he's crossed
over into pop culture.
He's such a big star now.
A tweet from him.
We'll hype the fight if I guarantee if
connor and Dana had conversation and Dan
was like,
all right man,
I understand it's a big fight cause you
gotta remember if you were to lose this
one,
now you're losing your golden boy.
The biggest star by far by far.
I also,
if he could just focus,
let's just let him focus a little bit.
Why I also feel like the magnitude of
this,
the dilemma that's in front of him and
Nate Diaz is also very apparent.
This is not a guy you can have ass.
And even if you are 100% ready,
you've never even fought him at 100% Oh,
you fought him when he had 11 days.
Notice what he'd been drinking in
Mexico.
I mean he poses typical matchup man.
And then you want to fly him on a plane.
Did anyone think,
man,
if you're looking at them with three
months away though,
okay,
but still connor's exhausted man from
doing all this stuff.
And also,
you know,
I see some fighters go,
it's our obligation to do these press
conscious slowly roll homie.
You're not conor Mcgregor press
conference.
That's,
it's a big difference.
And,
and,
and uh,
lost to him.
You're talking millions and,
and the UFC,
if I'm looking at as a businessman,
I go,
all right.
All right man.
He'll,
he's gonna do a press conference,
but we're going to come to him.
Did anyone think to do that?
Well,
first of all,
connor is one of the most charismatic
guys,
seriously of all time in all sports.
No doubt about it.
I mean,
he is a fucking marketing machine.
Like they're just the quotes and his
style.
His tweet player interrupt you,
but his tweet,
yeah.
Is the biggest tweet by an athlete this
year.
Beat Kobie Bryant's retirement tweet and
you want me to go do a fucking interview
for espn?
Well,
they don't know the sport.
Oh as well.
I watch ESPN every morning.
They were talking about Lebron James The
playoff game tonight.
They interrupted this shit with breaking
news cub out.
Connor's not retiring.
That's how big he is now.
The PR team at UFC could not get this.
They could not get this sort of
attention.
Even if they want to.
Connor can.
It's a different age,
man.
Those old interviews,
that old press conference,
you have a legit fucking superstar man
who makes more money than anyone dies.
Gates totally forgot what I was gonna
say.
Series points.
Sorry brother.
It's okay.
Sometimes I just go now what you need
you,
you have a,
you have all good points are all valid
points and I get this contracts,
I get stuff like that,
but there has to be where you can't have
a pissing contest.
You can't say,
well,
we're going to run it like a business
this time.
And then not this time.
Cause it's good for the company with
conor Mcgregor and this big of a fight.
If he wins this dude,
you know how much more money you're
gonna make,
not the fucking press conference.
He,
you're absolutely right that he's won
the most charismatic guys of all time.
But Nate Diaz right now is God damn
gigantic and I think we're going to
reel.
It was not as big.
It's kind of close,
but he's God damn gigantic.
He's huge.
And see what happens.
That's part of that fight.
Part of that fight is that connor is
also fighting another mercurial
superstar character.
I agree.
Especially now after the first fight.
I agree Joe,
but let's say connor doesn't fight at
UFC 200 and uh,
let's say nate fights woodley or Robbie
lawler.
Let me know how this rating scale fight
at one seven animals.
Let's say at one 55,
let's say fights.
Dos Anjos let me know how those ratings,
because here's where it won't be as
close.
We might even be a quarter of it.
I wonder,
it'd be close.
Maybe half.
Well that's the power sense though.
Maybe half half makes sense,
but half would still be pretty
spectacular,
you know,
at not even half.
I'm being generous when he left.
Now he's the biggest,
there's no doubt about it.
He's the Vegas.
Yeah.
Well who knows?
It's all speculation.
But here's what's interesting.
They offered the fight apparently to
normal go madoff,
but he can't take it because it's only
four days after Ramadan.
Fuck.
So he's very religious,
so he does that whole fascinating.
I had a buddy of mine,
my friend Concow alelee from back in
Boston.
He used to do that shit.
He would do that.
Um,
he would fast when he was training.
It was crazy.
You just,
you,
you have certain rules where you're not
allowed to eat any what?
How's it go?
You're not allowed to eat anything or
drink any sun up sun down,
right?
Yeah.
Do it.
And you can't,
there's no food or water.
Something Sunday,
crazy at like 6:00 PM.
They have this feast,
but it,
it can weaken you and so he'd be upset.
It would have a real,
it'd be a real problem if you had a
fight.
Four or five rounds.
I get it and I would love to see that
fight.
Habibi Nigga Murdoch verse Nate Diaz.
He's such a beast,
right?
He's phenomenal.
Yeah.
To us who are balls deep in the UFC
world.
Yes.
No,
you're right.
ESPN covering that fight.
Dude,
you should start a promotion.
Look at you.
You're a goddamn promoter.
You know how to do this.
I'm not.
I've been through it and when I see a
guy like conor comes in once in a
lifetime,
if you think there'd be another conor
Mcgregor,
you're bat shit crazy.
I think when we invest in arts,
the UFC,
the keep going.
I think you're crazy.
I think conor is a special dude and I
think there's a few other,
I think Brock Lesnar was,
I think Rhonda has theirs.
There's very few players.
Is it possible that this is a calculated
gamble based on not thinking he has
enough time to prepare for nate?
No,
I don't think some possible impulses is
just,
this is just a matter of digging your
heels into the ground and saying,
there's no,
there's no way I can do this much proud
of percent.
I think he's just like,
dude,
I'm exhausted.
You want on this world tour?
Is it?
Can I please get ready for this?
It's not the wwe man.
Go,
go,
ask,
go ask a major superstar Lebron and I
know you see you.
It's not the same,
but Lebron,
any of these guys,
these superstars in Sports Rinaldo gone.
These world tours not get paid.
Sell the fight when like,
and put my social media will cover way
more than this.
Go Fuck Yourself.
But we have no one fighting like he,
he can't say anything.
You say anything.
Look,
you got pulled from the car.
So more is not better is a certain
amount,
a certain amount.
You do well at a certain amount.
You're doing it for the UFC.
You're not doing it for the conor
mcgregor brand.
You're not doing for the fighters brand.
You think by him going to espn,
he's gonna get more followers.
Would you think that there's like
there's certain consideration that
looked like it looks good to have file a
fighters show up on espn.
He's been there,
he's on,
he's on breaking news.
He's,
he's,
he's been doing it maybe the week
before,
do it.
But when he wants to prepare for a camp
and you have a guy of his magnitude
coming off a loss and he's like,
man,
I really think doing all this press and
all this stuff has fucked with my
capabilities to be a fight.
I need to get back to that.
Will you please let me focus?
It makes it very hype.
The fight.
It totally makes sense.
Well you can't have exceptions.
No,
no.
Motherfucker,
you can cause you do make exceptions
because you have certain people in the
UFC roster where they can't,
you know what I'm saying?
Where they pick and choose when they
fight or who they fight.
There are exceptions.
Right.
And here's another thing to take into
consideration.
One of the most important things that
anybody,
any athlete does while they're in
training is get proper rest.
It's one of the most important things.
And what fucks up when you go traveling
all the time.
Your rest.
So number one thing that wrecks you,
you know,
let me think how much you travel too.
I just,
I just flew in from Seattle this
morning.
I got up at five this morning,
flew here,
got right off the plane and drove right
in here.
Yeah,
that's,
that's what happens,
man.
You're,
your body gets a,
your immune system gets jack from that.
So I'm good.
I just think of the,
I think this is great for the sports,
a good discussion to have because now
future superstars will say,
all right,
I'm only doing this,
may interviews this,
this much before the fight.
Well maybe when all this and to happen,
maybe there's a debate.
Maybe the debate could be held as to
like,
what is the,
what's the amount that you need to do
once the amount that you should do,
you know,
like what,
how do you have it set up and what would
be the,
what would be the best way for the
performance of the athlete?
The,
the consideration of their,
their,
their time and focus to put 100% effort
into something and not leave anything on
the table because they really weren't
rested enough cause we were or
distracted too much.
Cause they're doing too much press.
But who's it,
who's it helping the end?
The UFC and Dana white paper view.
If they have pay per view buys and they
get a percentage of the buys and it
helps,
it helps everyone.
But if the fighter,
I mean it should be a direct,
there's a direct,
if a fighter as a percentage of pay per
view,
which guy like conor does.
Yes.
The more pay paper view deals or maybe
he does it a title fight.
We don't know what his deal is.
So I'm talking about the for you buys
for sure.
I would have smacked her.
Why?
I would shown yes.
Um,
but so the more press he does,
the more things get sold,
the more money he makes.
But in his point of view,
like tweets and things that he's doing
right now are getting more attention to
it than any of these stupid interview
going to pay for this kind of publicity.
And you can't argue with that.
That's absolutely true.
But the question is like where?
Where,
you know,
there should be like a contract and the
contract should state from x to y,
you know,
pick a date and time.
I would be left alone if you sought or
wants to get me.
I'll be up in Iceland,
freezing my dick off thrown sidekicks,
come get me.
I see.
I think this whole thing is a misspeak
miscommunication.
I see Dana side and I see connor side
right as a fight.
I definitely see connor side.
I think it's just a miscommunication.
I think if before all this came out,
if conner was like,
listen man,
I can't be doing all this fucking,
I guarantee you have Dana was sitting
right.
There would be no miscommunication.
I don't think.
I don't think he would agree that it was
a miscue communication.
I think he would say the connor just
doesn't want to do the press.
And I just want to say what you gotta do
the press.
And to me that's a miscommunication.
But can I get some miscommunications,
a disagreement?
No,
I disagree because I disagree.
And this is why Joe,
because I think after,
after,
even though we fought Aldo,
he expressed,
dude,
I need,
she'll on these interviews,
he,
he beats a nate diaz or he loses,
nate does again.
He's like,
dude,
this fucking press is killing me.
So He's been voice in it.
And I don't know if his camp has had the
discussion with Dana,
but at some point maybe they haven't.
We don't know.
Maybe this is totally speculation.
We would say this communication down and
come up with a schedule.
Like you've got to leave me alone for
eight weeks,
but eat.
But what if,
what if Dana and connor had a
conversation right now,
man to man and Congos listen,
what I'll do,
I'll film videos every day.
I'll do this,
uh,
after my practices.
I'll put all this social media out for
you guys.
Craig this fight,
no one has the pull that I do and I can
create this many views for millions and
millions.
No other fighter can,
don't pay me for it.
Just don't make me travel.
You don't think Dana and the USC would
agree to any of this?
I bet.
I bet they'd be open to it.
You know,
it's interesting.
A Kevin Hart,
he was like one of the biggest stars in
the world,
one of the biggest,
uh,
comedians ever as far as like sales and
volume,
like not eight.
No one even close.
I mean,
he crushes it.
He sells out like,
what'd he say?
Like 50,000 dateless soldier field.
It's nuts.
Anyway,
that's not important.
What's important is he's,
he,
he's like gigantic on social media,
super active,
and he does it all himself.
So if he does a movie,
like he'll do a movie and they'll say,
oh great,
and you can use your,
you know,
5.8 million social media followers and
a,
it'll boost up the movie.
And it was like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
That's mine.
No,
if you want that.
Yup.
And we've got to talk about that first
guy,
dude.
They like that.
All the people that were in those movie
meetings must be like,
oh shit.
Because then the rock goes,
Huh?
Yeah,
because there's a giant difference
between a guy like the rock,
like what he can do to sell a movie with
media and the average person,
the average actor,
I mean he's,
he's constantly on it.
He has a dedicated loyal fan base
because he's really funny and self
deprecating follows us,
works hard.
So he's showing pictures of it.
Alarm clock,
it says like four 15 in the morning and
he's up there fucking doing dead lifts.
He's an animal,
right?
So a guy like that,
that's a business on the side,
that's his,
like he's got a hype business as well as
a business to promote himself,
but he can also hype things,
you know,
he's not a promotion once he gets some
money can be hard.
When he does that,
I'm sure he's got it worked.
It was talking about it and it's got to
work to the movies now.
So it's like,
Oh,
if you want a part of the Kevin Hart
money machine that I put together,
well you gotta give me something bitch.
Like she can't be any different.
You're right,
you're right in that respect as as,
as a superstar now not by fiber can pull
that card.
You legitimately have to be able to sell
out giant stadiums and be a superstar.
Yeah.
And he certainly can,
especially if you give them the right
match ups,
you know,
if you give connor the right match up at
one 45 like I think honestly,
I mean I'm excited about this nate diaz
fight cause I like watching them fight.
I like watching Nate Diaz fight.
I like,
and I love the attention he's getting.
But if I was,
if I was in connor's camp,
I mean I understand that he's obsessed
and he wants to get right back at it.
I would say go fight Frankie Edgar,
go fight Max Holloway.
Have a rematch of Max Holloway.
That shit would be epic.
I if all doe,
whoever Aldo does,
you know,
they mix it all up.
Fight a rematch with all dumb.
All those been talking mad shit about
him,
you know,
I think although genuine and genuinely
believes that he fucked up and if he
gets a hold of this dude this time he
get punished them,
which is awesome.
Fight and awesome stories.
I want to see it.
I want to see homeowners can't think.
So sites are still gonna be there if he
loses nate Diaz.
I think it takes some of the,
it takes a lot of the star power already
got taken away.
Too much of a risk.
It's just way too much power got taken
away.
And that second fight,
not 100%,
he's still the biggest draw,
but he was uh,
an assassin before that fight on two
span.
There was many,
whether s there was something going on,
like when he flatlined,
although with one punch and then did it,
like it was nothing and smiled and,
and I was talking to him in the
interview and he's just saying,
you know,
no power,
just,
just put it,
put it right where it's the nurse,
anything like it.
Yeah,
I mean the way he gobbled up the
pressure and the way he controlled the
shit talking.
This is the thing,
Joe,
we've,
we've never had a guy of his
capabilities and his mass appeal goat
man,
I don't want to do this like everyone
else has jumped through these hoops.
I don't.
I want to fucking train,
man.
This is ridiculous.
I'm already big enough.
We've never had a guy really do this.
He's also a guy where I think if he
wanted to,
if he was involved with the UFC,
let's say Dana,
which would never happen.
Cut Goes,
go do what the fuck you.
I'm sick.
You go do what you want.
He could sell out a giant arena in
Dublin against dot 5,000 every Saturday.
That's how powerful he is.
That's what I think literally making
just make more and more money.
Well,
I don't know about that because I think
part of the excitement about was
building up to that Aldo fight.
That was part of the man who would be
king story was that he was going to
fight the longtime king and when he flat
lined the longtime king,
he reached this level of legendary
popularity.
There does that.
It happens once in a hundred generations
when it comes with fighters.
There's this,
there's this moment,
this boom,
how many guys reached that moment?
Like when he flatlined Alto with one
punch and then it was in 13 seconds of
the whole world was like,
he fucking did it.
The answer is none did it?
Yes.
It's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
that was epic.
But the lustre gets taken off by the
Nate Diaz fight and if he loses to nate
Diaz,
he's got a very good point that,
you know,
he can't lose because he wasn't given
the right amount of opportunity to,
to present or to,
um,
to prepare himself because he had to do
all this prep.
Like right now,
the economy,
Greg Fan base and guys hugging his nuts,
which I might be one of them,
but he,
you know,
they're going well you know nate Diaz,
it's way bigger and he kind of caught
him off guard.
Well,
all that good and there's a little
asterisk I guess if you're this conor
guy,
well now if he loses again,
there's no more excuses because the fuck
there's no asterik.
Nate had 11 nights.
I'm saying it.
You could,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm not saying there isn't h straight up
beat him with 11 days preparing,
sipping corona's on a boat and came and
whooped his ass.
I thought [inaudible] was going to beat
him just by first of all the size and
length and deceptive boxing skills.
That's what I thought.
I was like,
this is going to be the first guy that
connor's ever fought that's been in wars
with like a legends.
I mean he's been in there with a lot of
fucking super high level dudes.
He's a monster and like this is a big,
big fight and this is not a fight you
want to take.
Even if he's not ready on 11 days notice
you've got to get ready for this dude.
And his Jiu Jitsu is off the chain.
Man,
his Jujitsu is at a super high level.
He's in x bigger than comment.
There couldn't be a worse match up right
bars with Andre Ward,
world champion and Joe showing on a
regular basis.
And his brother Nick.
I know Gilbert Melendez,
Jace Shield,
no joke,
no joke.
Dangerous fucking fight,
man.
Whore.
What's stressing me out?
I was fucking with Adrian,
the guy who we're not talking about and
all this is nate Diaz.
Cause even though if Nate Diaz and you
guys can say whatever you want,
you'll see 200 still going to be dope.
I get that.
That's all fun and Dandy for the f the
absolute fans.
If there's no connor,
nate doesn't make the same pay day.
So he gets fucked man.
You're right.
And I want to see a guy like the dues
that nate has paid.
And remember the Diaz brothers were the
first guys to go.
Not Fuck that man.
I don't think it should be done that
way.
And you've got appreciate that man in a,
in a land full of fucking sheep.
They were the first kind of wolves go,
no,
fuck that man.
This ain't right.
Well they're also the first guys to put
a ridiculous emphasis on extreme cardio.
Yes.
And it shows in their style.
Yeah.
I mean like nick doing marathons and
triathlons and a,
I was,
it's funny,
I,
I keep quoting this and nick corrected
me the other day.
I said that he swam back from Alcatraz
twice.
He just corrected me the other day.
It was five.
Now it's fucking
nuts.
Times he swam from Alcatraz to the
fucking mainland.
They didn't think you could do that.
They didn't think it was possible.
That's why they put a prison there.
Cause they didn't think people could
swim.
This motherfucker is a stoner and an
athlete.
He's not even a prisoner.
Oh fucking let,
don't lock that dude.
I'm going to swim right the fuck out.
He Oh,
creepy on a bunch of guys like him in
prison.
But how crazy are people these days do
be doing things for recreation gun.
The only,
the only guy who could bring nate Diaz
money is George Saint Pierre Grc pr.
I think we might begin honey Dick,
if George Saint Pierre does happen just
shell up at UFC 200 it's like,
wait a sec.
Well,
George has openly said that he wants to
go through a camp and decide whether or
not he could do it.
At the end of it,
he's done it.
Did he go through the,
the prep camp?
That's what I heard.
When did you hear this?
You got the inside scoop.
Dot.
I mean,
I know he's been training a shit load
and I know he doesn't care about belts
or anything.
He just wants to take the fight.
You know what the holdup is?
Why Reebok?
That's awful.
Okay.
Oh well you're George Saint Pierre
sponsored by under armour.
And then how many fights do you have?
And Reebok's and were like,
yeah,
here's whatever,
50 grand where these reebok pumps.
He's like,
what the fuck?
No Man,
I'm George Saint Pierre.
So he's saying either the USC has to
make up for it in his purse or reebok
has make up for it.
So I think it's a money thing right now.
Really?
That's what you hear.
Is this the inside scoop?
I don't know.
I think we just scooped a shit out of
this hell.
That's what I hear.
Well,
I've been hearing rumblings of
negotiations,
but uh,
you know,
it's one of those things you don't want
to hope.
You want to just wait.
But also I was the only guy you can save
the card.
Well he would,
he would most certainly save the card.
Oh my God.
You know,
it would be crazy.
Would be him and connor.
I mean that's fucking that Tammy Connor
Madison Square Garden to what you would,
it was not enough seats there.
No,
there'd be full of just fucking GSP
versus it looked like the Oscars is just
be as crowded full of celebrities.
Regular folk can afford the tickets,
especially if you get angry GSP GSP that
wanted to punish Bj Penn GSP.
I think it's really tough to bring him
out.
But you didn't like about rush.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
He was a motherfucker.
Oh,
GSP was one of the weirder guys because
he was such a nice guy.
At all times,
but when guys fucked with him,
there was this,
this switch that would go off in that
head and he would go on seek and destroy
mode and he was so good at it.
Man,
when he fucked up,
Bj fucked up Fitch,
you,
you wash those fights and you just go,
that is arguably the greatest
welterweight of all time.
I agree.
That mean his ability to mix up the
strikes and the takedowns.
We never knew what the fuck was going
on.
His,
his constant victories in a scrambles,
you know,
and the Bj fight to where he was
punishing Bj,
he wanted to punish him.
And when he,
when he beat him down,
it didn't stop them and then walked over
to the wall and fucking punched it
afterwards.
That's the mother like,
whoa.
Now does he come back or do we get that
that safe GSP cause a safe GSP verse
condom?
We're not,
I'm not trying to see that.
There's a lot,
there's a long time gone.
Who knows?
Who knows where G we're talking about
GSP and Bj.
Bj Penn's coming back to,
yeah.
Well I'm a,
I'm excited to see what that looks like.
BJ's fight and Dennis seaver and he's
been at Jackson Winkeljohn his camp for
quite a while now.
And so I'm assuming they're not letting
him cut any corners.
Uh,
not really running them through the real
paces.
If you're at Jackson's,
there's no cutting corners.
If you do your skin,
you're asked molly walked in and you
wouldn't be there that long.
Right.
And get back on a plane,
go home.
And why would he,
I mean he's been living out there for
quite a while now.
Hawaii down mccurdy Gee,
that'd be pretty legit.
GSP Negotiating Uba,
UFC return.
But Reebok deal consider considers road
blocker.
There's a story.
Mm hmm.
Yeah man.
I Dunno.
Just this whole thing bums me out.
It's complicated.
Yeah,
we'll see.
We'll see what happens.
But man,
hope becomes,
it would be the 200 to end it if you
think you saved for from asking square
guy and fucked too.
Do you think that would be nate versus
GSP of Connor doesn't do the car,
so connor's not on the card anymore.
He's off today.
He said,
I'm down to fight.
He even goes,
I will fly to New York and do a press
conference,
but then I got to go back.
So he's given a little wiggle room.
I think it's time to drop the egos.
Come to agreement and save 200 let conor
fight.
Nate.
We've is Brennan shop the reasonable
one.
How is this possible to the houses
fossil Kenogenic Diet?
Kido kid?
I was super positive.
Super clear mind.
I like everyone.
All right.
Set Dana Tax.
Yeah man,
it's,
it'd be interesting.
It'd be interesting.
We'll see if he could work it out.
I hope so.
Man will say it's fun guy,
man.
It's,
it's made it fun though.
Stylists,
tapings,
publicity holistically that slap on her
wrist form so I could fight for him.
I'm happy for nate.
Like,
I like both guys.
I'm happy for nate.
He gets,
he's finally getting the credit he
deserves coming out of his brother's
shadow.
Like we want this man to be announced to
be determined.
That is the,
the big fight.
See that?
Rest of the car.
Don't get me wrong.
There's some phenomenal,
are you kidding me?
Phenomenal fight.
It's an amazing car.
Look at this.
Look what's on the card here.
First of all,
although versus Edgar,
I can't wait for that.
I want to see what frankie can do now.
The new and improved frank and me too
and then although I feel like it's
declined a little bit.
I think the Chad Mendez fight,
the second fight,
he didn't look as good as he had looked
in the past and then obviously he's
coming off of a big loss.
My favorite fighter of all time.
It's a great fight.
And Tate versus Nunez.
Come on son.
She's needle mover,
right?
Yeah.
It's a fun one needle mover in my mind.
My needle's moving right now.
Might need aligns Moose for tate in my
mind and my,
yeah,
no,
that's what I'm saying.
That's more time.
Okay,
so that's a good fight.
That's a very good fight.
Nunez is super dangerous,
especially in the early rounds.
Yeah.
She tends to tire a little bit.
She tends to tire Lou.
She blows it out,
but God damn,
she's got some pop.
You've got a serious right hand,
real dangerous Moy Tai.
Then you got travis versus cats,
a motherfucker,
the heavyweight.
And that's a motherfucker.
Damn.
That's interesting.
The thing to me with cane,
it's like at what point all these
injuries and him come back.
At what point do we see him age?
Like we've seen Rashad,
right.
Come after amenities.
Rashad doesn't look the same.
There's sometimes when guys come back
you're like,
oh fuck,
that's not the same guy anymore.
At what point do we see k not come back?
It's true,
but keynes,
a mother fucker,
if he does come back,
good luck.
But again,
stylistic wise,
Travis Brown's up,
motherfucker form great takedown
defense,
obviously great at striking and he's
huge.
He's a big boy too.
Very fast.
Very good striking long wide base.
Good footwork and movement.
It's hard.
That's a good fight to really didn't
think he looked great in the material
and fight.
No,
that wasn't the best fight for him.
Uh,
but neither was the,
um,
they're all osteophyte.
That was a more disappointing fight I
think when he got knocked out.
Yeah.
But it was also even the trash brown
one,
it went down.
But even in the mitre owned one,
cause we saw them for longer rounds.
I was like,
Nah,
like crazy.
And then you get a guy like Cain,
man,
you're talking about a different
motherfucker to Travis Browne mature on
fire,
which is so unfortunate because the AI
pokes.
I agree.
So fucking,
and that was doing well in the first
round.
Then we got poked in the eye.
It was a little tough.
It was bad man.
Ms. I was horrible the way they handled
that whole thing.
Fucked Matt.
Yeah,
well he's got a lawsuit,
doesn't he?
Fire suit and you should.
But again,
that's just kind of let you know how
fight even goes down if they go three
rounds that,
I'm not saying Matt with a one that
travis definitely won the fight.
That was a great fight up until that
moment.
But whenever a guy gets poked in the
eye,
like the outcome is marred and when
you're fighting a monster with one eye,
it's going to be a tough fucking night.
Yeah.
But I tell you why I,
I don't mind.
Traps is shot here against cane.
I don't think he's that big of an
underdog and if he is,
I don't know what the odds are but I
mean travis has that one punch knockout
power knees.
Yeah,
it's,
we really don't know how much,
like you said,
of a toll.
All these injuries have taken on cane
and the time off me,
we only saw him that one fight with vre
doom where we blamed it and he did as
well on the lack of training at
altitude,
which makes side of my face right now.
You don't,
you don't buy it.
Fuck no,
that's we in it.
It's fine.
It's,
you don't get to his level and be like,
oh altitude.
I got tired cause out dude bitch you
knew for four months when we find out
that altitude,
but he's here for his cardio.
Maybe just overestimated his own cardio.
Is that Paul?
I don't think anyone in his camp was
like,
yeah,
that's pretty high up there.
We should probably go where Javier said
that it was his fault.
He said,
I should have forced him to go early.
You know,
sometimes guys just don't want to leave.
He just got beat by the other guy,
man.
It could be that don't buy that shit.
Could be that too.
He definitely looked tired,
but he the greatest of all time,
100% just had an off night.
Well,
verdomme is a big dude.
He's tall and long and he's striking has
come a long way in his Jujitsu is the
best in the business.
He's also browsers up for Cain.
I used to tell his teacher wise,
he's a bad match.
You take them,
hey,
take them down.
You got to get strangled.
Good luck with that.
And he's also not going to knock him
out.
So he gets [inaudible] and virgin can
jump to guard,
jump half guard.
It's a fuck it.
It's a horrible matchup for him.
So yeah,
he lost two gears.
Yeah,
I'm really bummed out that we didn't get
a chance to see the rematch.
I really wanted to see that rematch.
We're going to see it after this.
Maybe.
Yeah,
maybe it's a bit funny nose.
I agree.
Maybe it's a huge,
this is a huge,
maybe huge maybe.
And you know what man,
when I saw that fight,
tough fight for Kane and Steve Bay's a
tough fight for anybody.
Man.
Steve Bay is gonna fight for doom.
That's a tough fight for [inaudible].
Steve Bay's No fucking joke man.
He's no joke him and yeah,
no joke.
They,
that the odds are stacked against them
flying down to Brazil and fighting Berdo
yeah,
the odds are stats,
a tough place to fight.
But he's a geared up dude.
He's ready to rock and you know,
coming off of that big one,
punch knockout of overeem or of um,
uh,
Orlowski he looked good in that fight
and you look great,
you look good.
And he looked angry.
He's got momentum behind him.
I'm looking forward to seeing and he
will go to war.
We saw that in that five round fight
with Dosantos jds.
I mean he,
he took junior dos Santos to the edge.
That was a fun fight.
That was a wild ass fight.
Fight could've went either way.
It could have went either way.
So I think that he's right up there and
I think that's a really interesting
fight.
I'm looking forward to see you in that,
but put up that Cardigan because a,
there was some other shit we weren't to
talk about.
Look at this one.
We're saucy and Brunson people didn't
bring that up.
Your boy hendricks and need to win so
bad.
God does.
He does.
And that's a tough fight to men.
Kelvin is a good are becoming out.
I'm guns blazing cause he lost a magnate
last time and then also hendrix getting
stopped by wonderboy is going to charge
Kelvin up.
True
too man.
He's very fleet of foot.
You know,
he's got excellent footwork and tough
matchup.
Real light on his feet.
Fucking johnny comes with his aide game.
It's a rough night for Kelvin,
I think yacht.
Well it could be or who knows,
man.
Calvin could realize that he's got to
bring it up to 10 constantly in camp and
reach his full potential and that this
is an opportunity to really erase the
magnet fight and to get a victory over a
former world champion.
I mean that's gigantic.
Look at this.
You got Diego Sanchez and Joe lows at
that throwback son.
We call that throwback Thursday match
up.
This is the better fucking clean the
canvas special.
I agree to be some blood in this fight.
Okay.
Early,
early too.
So all those other guys are gonna have
to walk around that glut.
I used to hate that when there's a
bloody fight before and there'd be blood
on the mat and you know when you're,
when you first get any take that flap
around the outcome.
God Damn it.
We know what they do during the Fox
fights.
They spray paint over the blood type
move like Grace Gross.
We're sitting there doing the commentary
and talking about some stuff and they're
spraying like full bore paint booth,
like doing a Chevelle 10 feet
from us.
I'm not,
I'm not exaggerating,
that's like that bloodsport when there's
blood he's like scraping the mat and
then the next day comes out,
dude,
they spray painted,
they walk around and spray paint over
the blood and you're like,
are you fucking shitting me?
And everybody like the,
the,
the camera guys are covering their faces
with shirts and feel like in a way
better solution.
It's probably illegal masks on and stuff
for that shit.
You can't just blow it and can hound
fucking is 15,000 people sit in the
audience.
They're like,
well,
what's really important is we deny what
we're involved with.
That is a little spray paint on this
blood.
We don't want to assume your blood
blood's inside of everybody.
We need blood to stay alive.
Sometimes he's a bloody business,
but we don't want to look at it.
That is weird.
Yeah.
They're like airbrushing nipples over
there.
Stop it.
Did you say that's only on Fox or on
paper view or it happens all the toe.
It's only on Fox.
They would never do it on paper.
You the UFC knows exactly what it's
selling for sure.
Yeah.
They're not scared of blood.
Matter of fact,
some people like it shouldn't be scared
of it either.
Man.
What's going to happen?
You got in bed with the most exciting
sport in the fucking world.
It's happened,
so give it a blood.
Don't worry about it.
And during Fox fights,
I'm not supposed to talk about blood.
His mom's supposed to take it down a
notch.
I was supposed to non-manager.
I feel like they fucked up town.
You
see there's a little thing you mean?
He goes,
yeah,
I fucking go.
Well I shouldn't.
I mean there's no need to exaggerate it
and there's no need to dwell on it.
But if it's overwhelming,
what if it's over one guys like that
blood's fucking crazy.
Also,
the descriptives that I,
this is what I believe to descriptives
that I use during a fight half to match
how I feel about the moment that gives
me,
I'm giving a bear better narrative of
what I think is going on in a fight.
When I see Diego Sanchez face hanging
off of his head as he's chasing after
Martin Kampmann.
And I say,
this looks like a scene from a horror
movie.
That's cause that's what it really feels
like to me.
And if I don't say that,
it's probably not,
I'm not doing my job as what you're
doing.
The fans at this service.
You'd also not,
I mean,
that's why we love listening to Joe
Rogan.
If you start [inaudible] boxes and want
to know you're going to do it because
that's how you get to do it.
Going to wear a condom.
Everybody said,
Joe,
we need you to Tuxedo in a condo.
We have,
we bought our Fox condom.
They,
he's looking at in,
this is not on but not anti Fox.
I'd love that day of the UFC on,
I think it's amazing.
It's great for this.
I just think you've gotta stop.
Spray Peyton.
Me,
stop making me read that Shit.
Come on.
The poor camera guys.
Camera guys.
Five feet in front of me.
He's taking,
he's taking it right in the face.
Yeah,
man.
Uh,
he's coming.
No.
Why would the lawsuits come?
Nobody.
10 years.
If someone's fucking prove it,
just don't do it anymore.
Just don't do it anymore.
You can't do it like that in elementary.
I remember when the kid threw up and
then that weird janitor came with that
orange substance.
It was like,
whatever.
It's really shit the rest of the day.
I guarantee you there's health codes.
I guarantee you,
you can't just spray paint in a room
filled with people with no ventilation.
No one seemed bloodsport die or some
fucking dude just goes out there between
the rounds and scrubs the mat out it.
That's not good for the crowd.
The crowd is want to see that?
Fuck the crowd right now,
dude.
In that they're frauds though.
And you start spray paint and the matte
watching it.
They did.
They didn't put up a curtain.
What's going on behind the curtain?
I no one knows.
What's that smell?
We have no idea.
Fucking gray smoke is in the air of
what's coffin fighters like we were
calling.
I actually got away from the desk.
I put my headphones down and I backed
away from the desk.
I'm like,
what the fuck man,
I'm healthy bitch.
I'm the Kido kid out of a bitch.
Fuck you dude.
You don't think they'd get higher like
some,
I don't know,
former flight or with fucking cte?
Just a scrub the man.
And when he comes out everyone goes,
yeah,
he's a celebrity.
Plenty of sponsors on a shirt and shit.
And he's scrubbing the mat.
This is like a Ben Stiller's character
in that movie.
Tropic Thunder.
Like,
like you could see you having played a
guy like this.
Sure man.
Shit has gone bad.
That's awful cute magic had former
fighters cleaning the octagon and waving
to the crowd.
Broken hands.
Oh my God.
Holy.
Is that Juni Browning scrubbing the mat?
It sure is.
Yeah.
There's certain things that we will,
we have to maintain a certain level of
empathy.
Oh,
for sure.
I'm hair.
Just like certain people can't have that
job.
No,
no.
Once you're an all time great,
you cannot,
oh no,
he can't do that.
He came in to interview for the job.
I can't have you be could do it if you
want it to though.
Like if everybody knew,
he wrote,
okay,
what if you're like a super fan?
Like if Randy coture decided in between
fights,
he was going to help squat,
you know,
scrub the mats on.
He looked up at everybody and he waved
and Randy's and great health.
You know,
I looked at everybody,
wave to everybody and then got down and
showed everybody,
hey,
he's not too big to cleaning the blood.
He could do it if he wanted to do,
people would start crying in the stance.
I no,
no,
no.
His overalls on knee pads start
scrubbing the mat.
Shit.
But what I'm saying is he's still
successful right now.
It's not like he's down in the dumps and
everybody knows he's doing movies.
He's always doing the dependables big
expendables.
Better name,
expendable.
The pinnacle.
I mean everybody's nose.
He's doing well.
So wouldn't be you wouldn't want,
you would say he's just doing it to show
he's not above cleaning the blood off
the mat.
He said national treasury son of a bitch
can have ready to get door.
You need your Miata like data 5,000 and
this is racist.
I'm not sure.
Just cause he's scrubbing the mat.
Can't have randy do it.
I'll do it.
If,
if randy does that job,
I will fuck that.
Give me that brush.
Do it too.
I will rush and then I would do it as
well.
I feel like it's randy couture.
Man,
how did you take take it to randy to
door?
I was just saying randy could do it
cause he's that humble,
his stature because he's of his stature
because he's still,
he,
well first of all,
if you hear him talk you would never
think of other than looking at is
cauliflower ear.
You know,
you would never think that randy couture
had a lifetime of fighting.
No.
He beat the game.
He's killing it crazy.
And it joined some devil and is all you
didn't lose by knock out a few times.
And me heavyweight,
I mean he got killed by brock prize.
Oh well Liotta machida knocked out with
a flying time kick in his last fight.
Remember jumping front kick in the face.
So that was the Odo um,
I mean he had been knocked out by Chuck
Lesnar.
Bad lesnar.
Lesbian was a Tko but chuck was bad man.
Charlie,
Ben,
chuck torqued his head.
Yeah.
So you know,
there was two chuck fights were lost by
knockout,
right?
Yeah.
Either way.
Right.
Chuck,
he beat Chuck once and they chunk feed
him twice.
Correct.
I mean,
so anyway,
my point is,
randy talks perfect when you hear him
talk,
he's smiling and he seems happy as a
couple of guys I get so does Tito Ortiz,
he speaks pretty well to see Tito always
had like a little bit of anxiety on
camera that like would fuck them up.
Like there's those classic videos of
Tito when he was doing the affliction
stuff.
I'm not saying he's fucking bob costs,
that's just anxiety and he speaks well.
If you have a conversation with you,
there's no prison wrong with them.
No,
no,
no.
Good point.
And um,
you know,
there's a lot of other guys that have
been around for a long time.
They don't have anything wrong with
them.
You know,
there's a lot of guys that made it
through and you talk to them and they
seem absolutely fine.
Have you seen that,
that
movie concussion?
No.
That shit will make you question what
you're doing with your life.
Really.
I watched it on a plane before Brian.
I had one of our live fire the kids and
it fucked me up man.
Wow.
That really,
really crazy.
How much of is based on reality and how
much of it is a dramatic,
I looked,
I looked into it afterwards.
I mean,
you know,
I'll see.
For the movies,
they exaggerate stuff as far as the guys
dying in the head trauma and stuff like
that.
That's all real band and the NFL hiding
stuff.
That's all real.
That's why the lawsuit,
that's why all the NFL guys or the
lawsuit because they went,
oh no,
that's all fake.
It's not true.
There's no brain trauma caused by
football and they hit all of this thing
and by this doctor finding this stuff
and trying to rebuild it,
reveal it.
They were trying to fuck him over,
man.
It's nuts and that's all real.
All real.
See that's where it's crazy because the
NFL still in business.
Oh,
this guy's still around.
They can't get any bigger.
Yeah.
The doctor,
he's still around.
He's still around.
Yeah,
he,
but he didn't want to be involved in the
NFL.
They offered him a full time Gig to help
him out and he's like,
Nah man.
Wow.
I need to watch it so I know exactly you
need to watch.
It's fucking intense,
man.
I watched him.
I was like,
fuck,
look,
football's dangerous.
I got done and I just looked at Brian.
Brian goes,
what's wrong?
And I went fucked.
Brian started laughing.
He like,
what are you talking about?
I'm like,
watch concussion,
man.
He goes,
no,
you done that much like,
well,
20 years old.
Don't ever listen to Brian.
Oh No.
Have you ever think that something might
be wrong?
Go.
Never go to Brian because Brian,
I'll tell you,
you're fine.
The house burned down,
but it's because you know it's still the
place on it.
You can't.
You're going to camper for a few years.
That's Brian.
Tell her you love her man.
But Yeah,
man did that movie up.
Fucking some guys have made it through
even a superbowl careers,
but it's not a lot.
The problem is when they,
when they test former football players
for cte and alarming number show signs,
a ct,
an alarming number.
My only question is what you think was
going to happen.
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
I don't think we knew it to this degree,
but the same time,
like when I would run faith verse in
another giant man,
I'm like,
God,
it can't be healthy for my brain.
No,
you know,
but like the way they talked about a
concussion is if you put like a,
uh,
like an apple and a water bottle and you
shake it like there's water in there
that's like your brain where most like
a,
you know,
those rams,
that head butt each other like a
woodpecker.
They have mechanisms in their head that
absorb that shock,
but humans don't.
Right.
So when we run into each other,
your brain is smacking against this wall
cause we're not meant to do that.
We're not meant to punch each other in
the face and run into each other with
helmets on.
We're just not built for that.
No,
we haven't.
We haven't really developed the ability
to absorb punishment or if we had that
ability,
we lost it.
That's possible too.
Like if you look at neanderthals,
they were built very different than us.
You know,
they were very short and thick.
I think the only word like a little bit
over five feet tall and they weighed
one,
200 pounds and he's this big ass bones,
big thick bones.
They had bigger brains in ours too.
So they were built different,
you know,
and they,
and they were just dealing with shit all
the time.
When they find them,
they're always finding ones with broken
bones and fucking spearpoints lodge and
their spine.
Oh yeah.
That's a day in the life of a caveman.
It's not,
not a good time,
but our brains today,
like this body today,
like floating also you see like people
are becoming,
they seem like,
like if you,
if you look at people's like bone
structure in comparison to obviously
neanderthal,
which is a different species,
but some people retain some percentage
and the inner tall DNA.
But you would assume that as people go
further and further away from the
ancient hominins,
the ancient monkeys and stuff,
we're getting softer and weaker,
you know,
becoming more and more,
more softer for sure.
But yeah,
we're involved in like football's the
biggest sport in the,
well definitely the biggest sport in the
country.
Not The big sport in the world,
obviously that's our biggest in the
country.
If I fought a o two days,
Monday and Sunday,
which is not,
not only that,
and when we,
when there's a super bowl,
it's a fucking,
almost a national holiday.
Super Bowl Sunday is like,
everybody knows it.
Everybody knows superbowl Sunday,
everyone,
it's that big.
Like the world series can come and go
and people might miss it,
but they don't miss superbowl son.
Never.
But you know,
it's weird talking about,
you know those nuts.
The androgel w the caveman.
Yeah.
So nfl players actually getting bigger
though.
The athletes getting bigger and faster
and stronger.
Like they're getting way bigger.
Yeah.
The a 300 pound linemen in 1988 it was
like,
damn,
that's a big boy.
Now it's like,
do you know her bitch?
Get outta here we go.
Step your game up.
Yeah.
I wonder what that is still wrong.
What did they test in four?
Did they test for a shit in the NFL?
Yeah,
but you know you shits,
it's once a year.
Once a year.
Depends.
Unless you're,
unless you,
unless you've been caught before,
then you're in a program where you
getting tested all the time.
Well why would they catch them?
Why would they try to catch him?
Like what did I agree to approve?
Same thing.
Got Sports.
The,
this sport is safe.
Look,
we're testing everyone.
Shit.
But that doesn't,
that just makes you recover slower.
You know,
it's,
it's a weird dynamic.
It is a weird dynamic because you want
people to be gigantic and no one for
being,
no one talks about this.
And I,
I know it,
you know the WB fans are fucking
ruthless.
But how many wwe athletes die?
Like China just died.
But last night,
two nights ago we had the big girl,
China,
she just died like it kind of alarm
cause they're not a ton of them.
Right.
But when they get older,
they die.
What did China die from?
I don't know.
I think she was,
how old was she died in her house.
She 45 and 45 not that old.
She was on a fear factor.
Really?
Yeah.
Before she was bigger.
Like as a,
as big man.
She was a celebrity.
Yeah.
What's she doing on there?
She did some gross shit eating like
snails and,
but she did one thing and after she got
out of this thing,
she goes,
who's the man?
Oh fuck that flax.
She made the most muscular thing I've
ever heard.
My Laos.
She wasn't trying to be sexy.
I'm just saying as victorious.
Who's the man went into porn?
You remember that?
I do remember that as she hawked triple
x.
Yeah,
that was,
whoa.
Why no,
the typical one idea.
Don't ask.
Well,
I think when people don't have a whole
lot of options,
they start getting real desperado and
they don't know what to do.
That would be l Desperado doing she
hawk,
Aaa,
others,
her.
Oh,
that's you.
And that's you and her son.
Look at her muscles.
Look how skinny I am.
Feel like she would have fucked you up
back then.
I'll fuck her up too quick.
And my piece.
That's sad though.
So let's find out what happened.
Was it pills?
They don't know.
They don't.
They don't know man.
Super Nice man.
Real friendly.
She's real nice person.
She followed me on twitter.
Nice to everybody,
like on the set and everything like
that,
like a bomber man.
But I think it's conversation to have
like the substance they put in their
bodies and you look at their schedule
being on the road 300 days a year,
constantly falling uppers,
downers.
Like I know it's not legit.
I know it's not a legit sport compared
to the NFL UFC stuff and nbl or all that
stuff,
but it's,
you gotta talk about it because these
guys are passing away,
but there's no,
there's no regulatory,
like no one's making sure there's no
commission.
Well,
there's certainly athletes,
but I think a lot of people think of
them as athletes,
more of like a Cirque du Soleil type
thing.
Like they're doing a performance.
Then they think of them as in a sport so
they don't look to try to regulate it or
change it.
They look at it as sort of like an
entertainment thing.
These people were doing night,
you know what I'm saying?
I'm with you,
man,
I'm with you.
But they're taking some performance
enhancing supplements that a lot of the
pro athletes are taking even more cell,
I think,
because their schedules are way crazy.
Yeah,
no doubt.
So when they pass away,
I think there has to be some sort of
plan in place.
I think,
well,
the problem,
the problem is she hasn't worked for
them in a long time.
That's one.
And then second thing is if she was
doing pills or she was abusing other
substances,
they're not really responsible for that.
Like we don't,
we don't know how much of what she was
doing she was doing just because she was
in a recreational drugs.
There was obviously some steroids.
And I'm referring to the steroid show.
Oh,
you think that did it to her?
I think it was a pill.
I don't know.
Pill.
I think I'm pretty sure she overdosed,
dude.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well,
I'm not saying she overdosed on
testosterone some.
No,
and I'm just saying,
oh no,
no,
she was,
she was still on pain pills.
Oh yeah,
I'm sure.
Pretty positive.
That's what they're saying,
right?
A lot of people were saying,
right.
She was on the open gym not too long
ago.
She had just came back from Japan where
I think she had been living for the last
couple of years.
Teaching English.
Yeah,
doing,
getting away from the craziness of
American.
She was just coming back to get back
into life and entertainment and she was
found dead after not talking to anybody
for six days or something like that.
She went dark.
That sucks man.
Fucking,
I just think it's something to look into
with the Dojo.
You guys,
it's a discussion to fucking have at
least,
well,
I'm sure they must be having it.
It's a giant organization.
Chris,
ben Wa again,
there's one of those guys who goes off
the rails like that and does something
horrific and you gotta wonder like,
was that in that Guy Anyway?
Did he have issues already?
Did it have something to do with
wrestling?
substance abuse and Kushans they get
shemozzle concussions.
It could be a lot of different factors.
It's definitely something to look into,
but it's,
it's so rare that someone goes that far
off the rails like he did.
Oh,
I agree.
I'm just saying,
let's look at what they're doing to
their bodies and have a discussion about
it to maybe to make it safer.
So to prevent it from happening.
That's it.
I'm not saying I'll tell you,
but dammit.
I'm just saying,
I don't know.
Captain,
save a hoe over here.
Trying to save everybody.
Keep the want to do flips off the top
row.
What new possible overdose or natural
death where that natural at 46 no one
finds that fishy.
That doesn't seem to make a lot of
sense.
Dead on her bed after receiving a call
for,
okay,
let's just,
we don't need to read all the rest on
though.
She's a very nice person.
So rest in peace buns.
Hi know.
Nice Lady.
At least get it on a good note.
How about your boy,
Ben Henderson going for the triple Crown
Bella tour?
WC UFC belt.
No one's talking about it.
Not Nothing.
Who was he fighting?
He's fighting this rushing cat and I
wish I could remember his name.
I've even trained with them some even
bigger prick for that.
But uh,
it's a tough fight for Ben.
He's beat better guys with the top.
It's not a walk in the park.
I said it's weird that no one's bringing
it up at all.
See that's the disadvantage
of signing with Bella tour.
Yeah.
Because imagine,
imagine if he was doing this in the UFC.
It'd be fucking everywhere,
but it's all of course golf.
Uh,
we know what's interesting is,
um,
I don't even,
I mean I don't,
I don't watch half of the Bela Tarr
ones.
I don't even watch half of them.
I know,
I know.
They're probably pretty good fights.
I watch them if them,
if they're the major ones,
like obviously I'll watch bands,
Phil King,
Mo,
a lot of these guys that I like,
but I'm like,
what is missing?
What is missing from even drawing me in?
I mean,
almost feel like detached from it
because I feel insulted by the freak
show element.
Me Too.
I feel like it was a slap in my face.
Like,
I like,
dude,
you set us back,
man.
I feel like a dummy for watching to
really,
right,
I agree.
Yeah.
Whereas like I don't feel like that if I
watched glory or if I watch anything
yellow or if I watch one FC,
I don't feel like that.
I feel like I'm getting,
I'm getting shit on.
Like you're putting the other nonsense
might sound weird to say.
I almost feel like I'm cheating on the
UFC.
When I watched and I talked about,
I'm like,
Oh really?
Is that weird?
Yeah.
I think it's good to have competition.
I think it's important.
I agree with they have a ways to go.
They do,
but they,
they ended up good stuff too though.
They didn't have to,
if they,
if they did the right thing and promoted
the right way,
they went for like big ratings on a
couple of these weird fights which the
UFC did to sort of in the early 2000
[inaudible] tank habit came back.
Yeah.
I mean there was a few of those times,
you know,
you had to do that back.
I mean started,
they did some fights back then that were
in comparison,
silly,
but people didn't consider a sport
really,
but it was coming along.
But the sports already established now
and so they're taking advantage of these
old veterans like hoists and Ken
shamrock and having that fight and it's
going to draw in the casual nostalgic
viewer that remembers UFC one and
they're going to go and they're going to
watch it.
Snow s sustainability with that.
It's just not,
there is no sustainability.
And the other problem is that for
whatever reason,
I don't know what the reason is.
You're not hearing a lot of noise about
their champs,
you know and you kind of should.
It's weird.
We'll brooks is a bad motherfucker.
Michael Chandler is a bad mother fucker
fucker.
They got some great fighters over that
patriarchy pit bulls.
A bad mother fosters man,
very good fighters.
So it just seems like whatever they've
done wrong,
Ben,
Ben was on espn.
That's good.
He was on espn talking.
I'm glad they're given it.
Some press look,
they definitely need like the UFC could
use competition and I think it would
boost the sport whereas make the sport
bigger.
I just don't think that bell toward its
current state is competition.
They're taking a lot of fighters that
are past their prime except for Benson
Benson going over there as the biggest
coup.
I fail.
Phil's big.
It's not past his prime.
No,
but phil had been beaten soundly by
rumble.
He did have that really good fight
against glover.
Clover.
He beat Machida as true.
If I was super,
super close still though,
it's still a can speak Gustafson.
That's true.
But he strangled them.
Yeah.
So I mean,
but the thing about Phil as Phil Phil is
in a guy
fills fighting styles and the guy,
we were like,
I have to fucking see that you say that,
but in Beltour he looked fucking
sensational,
was like a destroyer.
Amazing.
He won by stoppage maize and maybe he's
off to a d in New star,
maybe recognizes the urgency of being in
a new organization.
She's one of the best fighters in the
world.
And going over there.
I think,
you know,
he was the first guy to do it and I
remember tax,
I'm going,
you got some motherfucking balls.
Good luck man.
You know?
And he's like,
yeah,
he texted me.
I'm so scared.
Hell yeah man.
It's scary.
It's paying off.
Right?
Because it was fat now.
Yeah.
And Now ben Henderson and they got mitre
owned.
Mitchell is a little older,
but at least a heavyweight Smith's young
can be champions.
So those are three completely legit guys
that they've acquired.
A stable.
Yeah.
Well he would have been interesting if
they got fade or it would have been
interesting.
Won't fingers playing grab ass and he's
fighting a on dot.
Yeah.
I don't know what type.
I might be wrong on this.
You might have to look at Jamie.
I think it's on fight pass.
What his fate or might be on fight pass.
I thought that fight really versus all
Denato rise in risen is on fight pass.
Come on.
Am I crazy here?
I'm making shit up.
Really?
I don't know this Keto genic died.
That's just my brain on another level.
It would be funny if you really nailed
it.
Um,
but the,
he's been saying lately that he's been
in talks to the UFC at it and I think
you'd give it a good go.
Cause you look at the state of the
heavyweight division,
everyone's old as fuck.
Don't you get your fossils?
But don't you think they put them
immediately with vre doom.
I like that matchup.
I liked her match of too,
but I think you have to do it that way,
right?
Fuck yeah.
He can't toss them like some young dude.
But what young dude do we even have?
We don't have one.
I don't know.
We don't really have a lot of,
uh,
I couldn't name one third,
but I'm saying for him,
like there's a resurgence of all these
older fighters.
We get Rothwell or Lawsky fucking hunt,
Frank Mir candy just lost with all these
guys are hold his fuck dude.
Fate or there's hope.
My man,
he'd still do it.
He never know man,
that skinny fat bill just fucking dudes
up.
If he still has that motivation and
there's drug testing.
I'm not saying he did something to say
bright.
I hate to Piss on the pride days but I'm
just saying it ain't the wild wild west.
We have to see your Dick this time.
Yeah we don't know.
We're just speculating.
I'm just saying it is.
Total fights are different as he looked
different but he doesn't weight train
anymore.
But I'll let me know what steroids do
you are taking cause I would never touch
them
because physically I'm going for look.
But he got,
he got thicker again before his most
recent comeback.
Like there was all sorts of posts about
it.
Ah,
online.
I saw some photos of him training and he
looked thicker back to the old days like
throwing around logs and shit look
better than their kettlebells.
We Shit,
it definitely looked like he had been
doing some weightlifting cause there
would come a time in his career where it
looked like the weightlifting days
rolling agree.
Like the early days he was way thicker
and bigger.
And then as he got older,
he concentrated more on skills and less
on strength and conditioning.
And that's not him.
And I think what I think you need both.
I think especially this day and age,
but when he was fighting,
fuck man,
I think he just put a lot of emphasis on
it striking in particular and his
ability to explode with combinations.
If you go like to the Tim Silvia fight,
the speed of combinations and he was
hitting guys with and his hips powerness
hip.
It's insane.
I do.
I think he has a legit shot shot to do
some work in the heavyweight division.
Now if you're his age and come back to
55 70 you're fucked.
But here's agent heavyweight.
Hell son.
What age is he?
36 now he has to be at least 38 39
right?
Or we'll find out if he him verse
Barnett something.
So back son,
don't think he's that.
Oh No,
I don't think he's that old.
39 wow.
Interesting.
I'm telling this kid or died.
That's my brain firing.
It's like shit out.
UFC offered feed or a million Eiko more
money than rising probability to fight
inside the octagon.
Very high.
Whoa.
Holy Shit.
That'd be intense.
Why is your boxing gloves on there?
Cause he's fucking,
but those boxing gloves,
those are those big assets.
Those are affliction where they're all
big.
Yeah.
Oh Wow.
They're huge.
I thought my close eviction.
Yeah,
those are flection.
Ansys they look,
they look a lot bigger than it.
Yeah,
they do actually the raps,
dude.
Can you imagine,
this is almost hard to say.
Can you imagine fader and a reebok kit
locked in the octagon?
I might buy that reebok kit if it was
white and red shade on the back.
Be the first kid I buy Sun.
Be Fun.
All right.
Just make my own.
I'd wear a fade or shirt for sure.
Fuck yeah.
I used to wear a cro cop security shirt.
Did you really fought them?
I bought it online for my Croatia and
came like nine weeks later and it was
too small,
but I still rocked it like my belly hung
out underneath it.
I was like,
fuck it.
No one really knew who he was.
I used to train that thing all the time.
How weird was it getting a call to fight
that guy after that?
So weird.
It might be the best collaborator in my
life.
Well,
it was the best.
One of the best results.
If you ever had any occupation might be
the better,
best joe after that,
if someone said,
hey man,
let's just kind of move on from here.
I'm like,
all right.
If he was showing me a crystal ball,
it's all right from here,
but I'll just move on.
What do you think of Osp and Jon Jones?
Um,
I think o s p he's an explosive guy,
but man,
John,
just too smart.
Too long to get caught.
I think.
Uh,
it's a good,
I hate saying this because Ospi such
good athlete and he's ranked in the top
10 or whatever,
but it's a good tuneup fight for John.
Wow.
I know.
It's fucked up.
My number's six light heavyweight is a
good tuneup fight for you.
Light heavyweight is struggling,
son.
Well,
sort of,
but not really.
It's like there's so much possibility
there in the top five.
Yeah.
What glow over just did to Rashad.
Holy Shit Man.
That was hard to watch.
It was hard to watch because you know
Rashad was super tentative and it was on
the outside.
It was moving away from glover and
clover.
Just close the distance and close the
lights.
The terminator,
there couldn't be a worse match up for
Rashad.
Like I just wish and I get it,
man.
People get well,
fighters fight.
I get that man,
but it was Rashad's stage in his career.
Sometimes you got to have a man to go,
dude.
Clovers,
a foe.
He does everything better than you right
now.
Let's figure something else out,
Bro.
What w I mean you win this one.
Are you going to fight for the title?
Probably not.
I think you've got to take whoever he
can.
You know it looks so,
look what we got here.
This is what I want to see.
Please.
Stephanie Johnson and glover Hamas,
especially at clover called for it.
That's the best fighter in the UFC right
now.
Please make that happen.
If there's one fight that could give me
go to UFC fight,
you'd be that.
And by the way,
I dunno who the fuck to bed on me.
Neither about that.
Me Need,
you should give be chaos in both
directions.
I think if it goes past first round,
glover takes over maybe.
But that first rounds can be a
motherfucka first round is like one of
those scenes in a movie where we're like
a building explodes and you have to run
through the rubble without hitting you
in the head on a,
you got a a minefield to navigate when
you're fighting rumble because one
mistake,
if that doesn't get you crunk,
you're an idiot and it's Gustafson
retiring.
I come in here and that Gustafson
doesn't want to find it.
I like he,
I saw an interview you did where he's
saying he's like lost the passion for
it.
So he came to San Diego hoping he could
find it and I'm not sure if he did,
but when you start talking like that,
I want you to look at the top three
because Glover Anthony and John Jones
will rip your Dick off and they want
this more than anything.
So it's probably time to maybe give it
up.
It's interesting that bater well I guess
Bader beat over and St Pru so he should
be ranked above them.
True.
And then Rashad shoguns still in the
mix,
Huh?
Dude.
Eight.
You're crazy.
If you think light heavyweights.
Good.
Well Shit
that kio gets me on another love on him.
He didn't say shit.
It is look past six.
Fuck you.
Well Vince,
um,
Rashad Shogun,
Jimmy Manoa,
Jimmy man guy.
Jimmy Mattawa is a guy that just was not
in martial arts that long before.
He's fighting top level guys to mma who
utilize a sick athlete with ridiculous
power.
And I just for games changed.
No one gives a fuck cause now you have
real fighters.
Go what?
You're fast getting and punch out power.
That's cool.
I'm just going to take you down.
He fought rumble humble man when he
fought rumble.
Well,
Gustafson stopped him before the rumble
fight in a very important fight.
Why they do them like that?
Here's rumble.
Who's guts the same?
Damn it.
Damn.
Double whammy of death.
You're fighting a guy that's boxing you
up for another zip code and you're just
like fuck.
And then you get a break.
Well,
in the UFC you bitch and then you fight.
Rumble Dude's got literal nuclear
weapons.
Pride at the end of his hand,
they got shogun and little Nog in the
top 10 that's a hard sell.
Especially especially in little little
Nog is a hard sells a top 10 guy.
And that's a good argument that,
that no one,
yeah,
there's no,
like you look at the,
you look at the heavier divisions and
like at heavyweight,
I mean there's fun.
Matchups everyone's old as fuck though.
Really man.
And they look at light heavyweight.
There's not a lot going on out to the
side,
the top five and in the top five.
Alexander does he know if he wants to do
it anymore,
it's very important.
Yeah.
Very,
very good point.
But why do you think that,
Joe,
why do you think these bigger athletes
aren't gravitating towards mixed martial
arts?
Well,
I don't know if it's that or if it just
comes in waves.
You know,
I think sometimes you have a guy like
Jon Jones and they create a bit of a
bottleneck because they're so good and
we can't forget about cornea of course.
So just in that alone,
you've got John Jones and Cormier
cormier.
He's as good as anybody in the world.
He got Anthony Johnson who can knock out
a tree.
You got Glover,
you got Gustafson,
and who knows what could or couldn't
happen this weekend with ovince Saint
Pru.
You know the guys on that list,
when I'm looking at him,
I'm like,
well,
these are,
there's,
you've got at least one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six,
[inaudible] six legit world beaters six
legit.
But you're talking about the biggest
organization in the world.
After that,
it's like,
yeah,
not much going on.
There's no young talent.
We were like,
dude,
he's the,
there's no sage.
Northcutts happened in cycles and weight
classes because there was no one at one
85 for awhile.
One 85 was struggling for a while.
Let me see,
one 95 one 85 now you've got it.
Well,
you know,
once Anderson loss and Weidman came in,
now you've got look at this crazy mix
and I don't know what they're going to
do with Yoel Romero,
but what I understand is that he has a
very small window,
uh,
where they're going to ban him for like
only like five months.
Yeah,
yeah,
he did.
What he did was totally,
he was actually honest.
They got the stuff independently off the
shelf that he said that he took.
They took that stuff and they tested it
and it had low levels of whatever this
peptide is.
It's supposed to grow testosterone in
your body or something like that.
So he really didn't take anything that
he wasn't supposed to take.
He took something that had something in
it that wasn't supposed to be in it,
and he proved it.
But Joel,
even if you,
if you go through middleweight look,
okay.
Vietor a he ain't that young.
Bisbing I mean,
yeah,
not young.
Has One eye.
Anderson Silva.
Okay.
Like fell off Leo Machida,
well,
older,
uh,
Musashi.
Tim Kennedy lead.
He's like,
there's not Dan Henderson's in there.
How has Musashi ranked above Uriah Hall
when you're riding hauled jumps,
spitting back,
kicked him in the face and stopped him?
Whoever votes on this thinks it's the
flu.
Those are ridiculous people.
That is a ridiculous ranking.
They're the ones writing articles that
can not be two steps above a guy.
When the guy stopped you in your last
fight.
That is weird.
You cannot,
I wish our boy Tim Kenny,
that's just an,
that's an arrogant assessment of
someone's ability in comparison to
someone else's ability.
That's not based on facts.
You have to base individual interactions
between two fighters.
You have to base them on facts.
It's very black and white.
There's no doubt about it.
The uriah hall proved himself to be the
better fighter.
Gay Garden was saucy.
Took him down and control them in the
first round and the second round,
Uriah Hall Jumps,
Spinning back,
kicked him in the face and knocked him
ass.
All that that is,
there's no more definitive ending.
This is an insult to him to have him at
number 10 and half gay guard at number
eight.
The only thing you can do with these
riders,
so cause it's basically a popularity
contest,
right?
If guy keeps winning a popularity
contest,
but the chance he can't deny it right
though the champion one and two,
it's kind of,
there's no honey dick.
You see one Brazilian writer put fucking
notorious mma.
He put him four notches lower after he
knocked out Aldo.
Yeah,
Connor.
Yeah.
How crazy is that?
How the fuck could you do that?
Well,
I don't know how,
but why does anyone take these series?
But that's why.
How could you do that?
I mean you might not like connor,
you might think the connor's a brash guy
and he insulted your champion and he
insulted your country and Blah Blah
Blah.
And then he smashes him with one punch
in 13 seconds.
It's just not professional and I'll
can't,
you're fucked.
Like no one can take your word for
anything.
I mean,
how the fuck do you drop that guy down
four points with a perfect performance?
Well,
I think for the fans it's like go check
it out.
Six verse 10 like it makes the more
mainstream like go look at six
[inaudible].
That's the number six and the word verse
number 10 but he can't remember when
they didn't do reebok based off rankings
and even the fighters like what the fuck
are you talking about?
Those rankings and then even Dana was
like,
yeah,
that's some bullshit.
Yeah,
Anderson versus your eye at hall is
going to be very interesting.
That's in Brazil brother.
That's in May.
That Brazil cards a motherfucker's
stats.
I heard the promo on.
It's sick too.
It's just a bunch of Brazilians
antelope.
That's an intense card,
man.
That's a very intense card.
Look at this.
I forgot about [inaudible].
Oh good Lord.
Yeah,
look at that Brazil card.
Oh Shit.
Cyborg Leslie Smith.
She deserves some sort of award.
Right?
Fucking now know she's fighting Cyborg.
He's going to rip your face off.
What?
Courage.
Why they have Cyborg?
No picture on the left,
but a patient ready for it.
They're not ready for it than not even
ready.
Go back to the other card are the
Arlovski fight.
What was hard was outed as a motherfuck.
What card was the Arlovski fight on?
One fs.
One card.
Ooh,
that's an interesting fight,
man.
And whenever I count or Lawsky out,
he comes back wins again like the
terminator.
How many times has he been stopped since
sane number now it's like very high
number.
He's been stopped at gang at.
Don't fight as long as he does and not,
especially at heavyweight.
And I get stopped.
Look at how many times it's overwritten.
Been stopped to look at that.
I've seen over him get with flat.
Look at Albert to Manav versus Gunnar
Nelson.
That's a great fun.
Ooh,
that's a good fight to went off as a
motherfucker.
Damn.
Struve back.
Big Foot.
Silva bigfoot and he's a figure it out.
Now they have this drug test and it's
tough,
man.
Yeah.
It's hard out there for a pimp is a
heavyweight.
See a lot of guys get stopped as part of
the game.
Who else is on this weekend?
Go back to this weekend's card
that that Brazil cars.
Ridiculous.
Leslie Smith,
that salty record,
eight and six sign up to fight Cyborg.
I wonder how Cyborg is going to deal
with the one 40 cut her first time I
dropped on onto one 40 inches faces off.
I think everyone should fucking run
every girl in the divisions like fuck.
Well I hope they give her a one 45 pound
division.
I think she deserves it.
They've had that division to Invicta.
It's an established division.
There's plenty of girls out there that
it will,
that'll fight at one 45 and that way
she's not dying trying to make the
weight.
She's a big girl man.
The thing is how many big girls are
there that they like?
Is it sustainable,
sustainable?
Let's find out.
Can you do that though?
Or Gina Carano did it and strike force.
I mean that was the whole thing or a
lead Xc,
right?
Was it strikeforce a leader because he
is the leading city lead ECC.
That was her whole thing.
She was fighting one 45 Joe,
look at my face.
I'm looking at your face.
You can build,
you can build a division around Gina
Carano and she looks like you can build
a division around Cyborg when she
smashing checks.
You can.
I firmly believe you can build a
division around,
sign up for it.
No,
you catch it.
If she watched Tyson,
every,
every little girl she runs into,
you can't do it.
You can do it.
I can do it.
And you and you have her keep talking
shit to everybody at one 35 it'll come
up to me if,
I mean,
come on box tattoo.
Come on dude.
She's a monster.
I like it.
Yes.
She's a mine.
Like I like getting me giving her a shot
at the 145 pound title maker.
She wanna have her fight this fight.
You gotta Fight Leslie Smith and
normally fights at one 35 you may get a
catch weight fight because leslie is
brave enough to take that challenge.
But then we create a one 45 take some of
them in.
Victor Girls Agree.
Jo,
I think,
I think you,
what do you do with her then you make
you make her fight at one 40 we don't
even know how well her body is going to
handle that,
right?
Let's say she does decent though,
but all your superstars at one 35 so let
me just do these super fight.
The one 40 where Misha could be champ at
one 35 or one 40 right?
And you have this monster at one 40 but
at least she's fighting Misha tate and
getting that coverage of Ronda Rousey
and Holly Holm,
right?
If you do one 45 okay,
now we've got to find a 145 bad ass is
at one 45 girls.
Well,
the real fight at one 40 is holly,
who's fought as high as I want to say.
She fought it like one 50 before inbox,
right?
At 1:50 AM one 52 so that would be the
fight because first of all,
she was without a doubt the most
experienced striker in all of the UFC.
It's women's divisions as far as boxing
competition and in a competition and
kickboxing.
I mean,
she's,
she's a 19 time boxing champion.
She's won kickboxing titles and she
wanted the UFC crown.
I think she's the only female in the UFC
who can beat Cyborg.
See,
that would be a fance fascinating fight
because she's got that style of
like counter striking and moving away
and almost a karate base with a lot of
athleticism and footwork.
And cyborg is just a destroyer.
But what happens when you go forward on
Holly?
You get fucking murderer.
So the girl like Cyborg coming forward
is tailor made for Holly.
All these other girls enjoy that.
Maybe enjoy frank the tank Brazilian.
I just don't know.
Um,
I mean she's bigger and stronger.
It's going to be an,
and she can take a punishment.
She did a lot of punishment.
Do you see the [inaudible] barge fight
in lion fight?
I did not.
She fought Sharina.
Yeah,
it was a fucking months.
She lost Cyborg gas boss' decision.
Well she,
it Tko no,
she lost by decision,
but she got punted in the face.
She got teeth,
face face.
Barsh is no joke,
man.
She's one of the best Muay Thai fighters
on the planet world champ.
She's so slick.
Her style is so good and you know she
has none of the physical attributes at
Cyborg has cyborgs,
just so strong and so powerful.
Again,
I think it's tailor made for Holly.
Every,
any other girl is fuck.
Interesting.
I would like to see it.
I'll tell you that any other girls get
her titties ripped up.
I just,
I don't want to see,
this is what I don't want to see.
I don't want to see cyborg fight
diminished so much from the weight cut
that we don't get to see the real
cyborg.
I don't these you've been bending enough
draw to create an entire division four
and breathe out and try cause we're
trying to build up one 15 one 25 right?
I think there are 35 see I think if
anybody's going to do it,
it's going to be a woman who knocks
women out.
I think anybody's going to bring light
to the division.
It's going to be someone that just not
working.
She,
man,
if she was like,
how young prospect,
I think you invest doesn't have to be
the level that she's adding comparison
to the level the other girls are at.
It's very,
it's very high.
The only thing that would change is if
one of those Moitai checks started
looking at Cyborg and went,
Oh really?
Oh,
okay.
That'd be so okay.
Okay,
well this is,
you know,
she's not going to take you down.
Most likely she's going to try to stand
with you.
If these girls like really concentrate
on the grappling and they really
constant,
you know,
six months sprawl training,
man,
now we're years out from that.
Well maybe you got to invest.
If you're going to do it,
you got to invest in that whole trend.
But look at a girl like tiff time bomb,
right?
She's,
she's starting MMA now.
You know that strength.
Yeah.
Well if you know,
during a prime like Miriam Knock Bodo
like someone somewhat along those lines
when the really high level female Moy
Thai champions,
they would be Merkin checks and mm sure.
If they could just keep the fight
standing.
Did there's levels out there and there's
levels of striking that we just really
haven't seen in the UFC.
And that's one of with a,
with some of the women fighters.
Um,
but I think that's what we saw in the
bars fight with Cyborg.
We saw that super,
super high level Moy Tai against the
marauding style of Cyborg.
And so I watched that fight and I said
two things.
I said,
one amazed at Cyborg has the guts to
take that fight because it's a dangerous
fight.
Nobody wanted to fight bars for like
three fucking years.
Couldn't get a fight.
And then how off the fact that signboard
takes tremendous punishment and keeps
going after I was thinking how many
other people in this division would
fight this girl?
I just,
holly and,
and keep getting knocked down and keep
jumping back up and attacking.
I agree.
Not a lot of female MMA fighters would
have been able to even stand in there.
[inaudible] only her striking kid bill.
She's literally the only one.
Every other girl with her head would
have been kicked into the,
and of course John Jay check.
But she's a smaller,
which is too small.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
I'd think a,
I think the 45 pound division man,
it could open it up.
Women Only having two division I think
is weak.
Right,
right.
But this is the time start to 45.
This is the,
oh,
the inaugural fight.
Right.
I'm not sidebar goes out puts on a show
against Leslie Smith,
knocks her face off or doesn't,
who knows?
She loses you don't have a decision,
but if she does,
if she wins,
right.
Boom.
You got to,
you got a cyborg fighting.
Someone legit for the championship.
Marla's Kuhn come,
comes over from INVICTA,
right?
She's in Victor,
Yeah.
One 45 or is she bella tor now?
Oh,
she's to,
that's right.
She has booked or her last fight.
Isabelle scooped her up.
But uh,
I,
I don't think you can do that.
I think you have to,
uh,
you have to do a super fight with
Michelle or holly and keep that on.
You have to do a super fight with me.
Sure.
Holly,
to create the buzz around cyborg cause
the average friends like who the fuck is
this girl ripping girls' faces?
There's another fight this weekend that
nobody is talking about.
Whitaker and the tall at your fight of
the night.
Ooh.
Robert Whitaker
man looks sensational.
And his last fight against Uriah Hall,
I was like,
Holy Shit.
This kid is throwing at your fight of
the night.
He's a dangerous guy.
Interesting.
How,
what a change it's been for him going up
to one 85 he just looks so much
healthier.
Way more powerful.
Way more confident.
Way more aggressive.
Just doesn't feel as diminished.
I think it was just too big for one 70
and the towels a beast.
The talls fun to watch,
man.
Very dangerous man.
Real good.
You'd have to till the wind.
Yeah.
And so gracie guy,
Dude Rodriguez though.
That's your young buck.
You're up and comer.
Young Bucks.
Yeah.
Rodriguez and Andrew feely.
That's another fucking Badass fight.
Ooh Wait,
that's a very good fight,
man.
I love watching Rodriguez fight,
Yeah,
he's fun.
He's wild dude.
He's wild.
That guy throws,
why you ever seen him train?
So Larry?
Yes.
Uh,
well he was at Jackson's for a little
bit,
right?
There's videos of him hitting pads,
dude.
He does like three 60 roundhouse kicked
three 60.
We'll kick jumping front kick round,
kick side kick.
I mean the way he mixed his shit up.
It's like who does that in pad work?
But he does it like he fights.
Have you seen it yet?
Have you seen him go for like knee bars
and like let's fucking like flips to
tone dude,
it's fucked.
The future man.
His ground game is no joke cause
grabbing on the very good,
he's got everything going for him.
He's wild.
He's unpredictable.
He's young,
he's brash.
Damn Andre threw up when I was
interviewing him.
He threw up.
He's the only guy I've ever talked to.
Like in the middle of talking to him,
he threw up in his shirt a little bit
and then he threw up on the ground.
Damn.
It's that cardio son.
We had a crazy fight.
It was a wild ass fight.
So that's a good fight.
Then.
It'll be a fun card.
They get the top bar is taking it to the
spotlight a little bit.
Yeah.
Well he definitely is and that's just to
be expected.
He's,
I mean he's the biggest star in the game
right now and I hope they work that out
for UFC 200 would be even better story
if it worked out.
They do guarantee they do.
I would almost guarantee they do or they
do a GSP nate diaz fight.
Then we got honey dick and then some
smells fishy.
Something smells fishy for sure.
If gsps like what the,
Hey,
I've been training or if they come with
the cash that come with that fucking
reebok makeup money.
I bet you I bet you a reebok that was a
set of reebok pumps and 6 million shit.
You go push it in for this shit in.
We're all in for GSP.
I think a,
I bet they figured it out.
Yeah,
I bet.
I Bet Yukon or ends up fighting in UFC
that's why.
That's what I believe in and that's,
I think Dana and the UFC brass is going
to figure it out.
I think GSP,
Nate Diaz takes its place and they use
it as a negotiating tool because the pay
per view numbers are bigger than any of
the connor fights because the UFC has in
fact grown through their strategy.
See,
I don't think the numbers beat Connors.
What if they do?
Well then you get then,
hey,
then connor's GSP and nate Diaz that
you're like,
Ooh,
connor fucked up.
Yeah,
I kind of fucked up.
I don't think you'd beat those numbers
though.
So osps best chance for this weekend.
He's got to win by knockout first round.
You think so?
Yeah.
That first round,
he's going to have to fucking caution in
the wind.
If he tried to sit there and fight,
you know,
like on the outside and out technique,
John Jones,
you're going to get fucked up.
That's going to be interesting to see
John with such a long layoff too,
with a lot of pressure on them.
But I mean you,
this is what I think's going to happen.
It's just me speculating,
I think,
and I've trained with both of them.
I think John Will.
They'll feel each other out early on.
John's going to get ahold of them,
trip them down the ground,
crucify him and tk on with elbows.
Wow.
I had to bet on,
I bet John Finch to them on the ground.
Really?
All right.
You heard it here,
folks,
this weekend.
UFC One 97 brandon schaub fighter and
the kid.com f fat t k three d.com t fat
k three d.
That's the new one yet.
The final a kid three.
Your your videos that you guys are
doing.
Yeah.
How was that?
It's a fun.
Oh,
the best.
Go Watch it.
You fucks.
Yeah.
All right.
Uh,
I'll be back in a little bit with
another one.
That's right.
You're a beast,
not in podcast.
Love you,
brother.
Dan Auerbach.
Excuse me.